good afternoon excellencies
you're most welcome to the chamber and
you're kindly requested to take your
seats
the seventh plenary meeting of the 11th
emergencies a special session of the Gen
assembly is coach to order
before proceeding further I would like
to remind members that all meeting
participants are encouraged to consider
wearing a mask while indoors including
in the General Assembly Hall and in
conference rooms
members will recall that in paragraph
five
of its resolution es 11 5 of 14th of
November 2022 the assembly decided I
quote to adjourn the 11th emergency
special session of the general assembly
temporarily
and to authorize the president of the
general assembly to resume its meetings
upon the request from member states end
of quote
in this regard I should like to draw the
attention of the delegations to document
a slash es 11 14 which contains the
letter dated on 10th of February 2023
from the permanent representatives of
Albania
Australia
Canada
Guatemala Japan the Republic of Korea
the Republic of Moldova turkey
Ukraine the United Kingdom and the
United States
and the head of the delegation of the
European Union to the United Nations
addressed to the president of the
general assembly requesting the
resumption of the 11th emergency special
session of the general assembly
I intend to conduct the proceedings of
this meeting in accordance with the
rules of procedure of the general
assembly
and the past practices of its emergency
special sessions
in keeping with established practice
I should now like to invite the
attention of the general assembly to
document a slash es 11 15.
concerning member states that are in
areas
in the payment of their financial
contributions to the United Nations
within the terms of Article 19 of the
charter
may I take it that the assembly duly
takes note of the information contained
in this document
so decided
in this connection I should like to
recall that at the 12th plenary meeting
of the 11th emergency special session
the general assembly decided to follow
the provisions of resolution
77-2 of 7th of October 2022
by which the kumaros
sautuman principle and Somalia are
permitted to vote in the general
assembly until the end of this 77th
session
and to also allow these member states to
vote at the 11th emergency special
session
the general assembly will now resume its
consideration of agent item 5 entitled I
quote letter dated
28th February
2014 from the permanent representative
of Ukraine to the United Nations address
to the president of the security Council
s slash 2014 slash 136.
in connection with this item the
assembly has before it a draft
resolution issued as document a slash
es11
L7 and draft amendments contained in
documents a slash
es11l L8 and Es a slash es 11 L9
okay
Mr Secretary General
excellencies
distinguished delegates
today we Mark the Grim first anniversary
of the warrior in Ukraine
one year of despair
displacement destruction and Death on a
scale of not seen in Europe indicates
The Staggering scale of loss defy the
human ability to absorb
thousands of civilians and soldiers dead
countless more injured
eight million refugees
spread across Europe and Beyond
six million internally displaced
two-thirds of them women and children
with families separated often not
knowing about the fate of their loved
ones
and the systemic targeting of Civilian
infrastructure which has left millions
of ukrainians without energy water and
heat in the depth of winter
to be clear
the targeting of Civilian infrastructure
is a direct violation of international
humanitarian law
when these are the headlines of our day
we are indeed in a new chapter of
History
we are facing stock choices
about Who We Are
as an International Community
and how we will rebuild the trust lost
Among Us
here in this hole and in US
by the peoples of the world
the choices
will either set us on a path of
solidarity and Collective resolve to
uphold the tenets of the U.N Charter
or a path of aggression
War
normalized violations of international
law
and collapsed Global action
excellencies the general assembly has
condemned in the strongest terms
Russia's aggression against Ukraine
and it's morally and legally
indefensible war against its Sovereign
neighbor
for a full year the Gen assembly
the Secretary General and the
International Community have been
consistent and vocal in our cause to end
this war
and to adhere to the U.N Charter and
international law
but it Bears repeating today
aggression is illegal
invading a neighbor
is illegal
annexing and other countries territory
over the past year
every member states represented in this
whole has been affected by these events
it has sparked an energy crisis across a
continent
and caused pernicious inflation far
beyond
it has Unleashed a global food security
crisis in those least able to survive
one
from the drought effect affected Horn of
Africa
to warn tone Yemen
to refugee camps of Syria
I comment the Black Sea grain initiative
and efforts by the Secretary General
Ukraine and the Russian Federation to
ensure the clearance of food experts for
Global markets
I call on the parties to support it it's
renewable in March and to expedite
inspections
they continued And Timely implementation
of the grain initiative is critical to
saving lives and stabilizing Global
prices
it offers a strong example of Crisis
Management in action
against this backdrop
the threats of nuclear warfare still
loans launch
as do
the dangers of a nuclear accident
a Dynamics
this is an unthinkable threat with
potentially catastrophic Global
consequences
a nuclear war
cannot be won
and it should never be fought
I express my strong support for the
important work done by the IAA to ensure
nuclear safety in Ukraine
behind the score the urgent need
to reaffirm commitment
to Global disarmament and the
non-proliferation regime
excellencies
no one can be com can be complacent
to all those suffering the consequences
of this war
you are not forgotten
we see you we hear you
across the U.N system we are working
tirelessly to find solution to your
plight
and to accompany you on the road to
reconstruction
I comment member states that have
already begun to provide assistant that
assistant
and call for further support to rebuild
the country
in the Gen assembly there has been Firm
support for a political solution
three resolutions adopted during the
11th emergency special session have
referenced political dialogue
negotiations
mediations or other peaceful means
a solution based on the U.N Charter and
international law
and one that respects Ukraine's
sovereignty
and territorial Integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
excellencies
this war
will come to an end
and the time of reconstruction
reconciliation and transformation
welcome
we know it will not be easy
we know the scars are deep
culture
family bonds
Sports arts and the acknowledgment of
the shared Destiny of humanity will
certainly help Nations currently facing
each other in the trenches
please allow me to now address the
leaders and people of the Russian
Federation
Russia was and remains a major member of
the community of Nations
other members
are
waiting for Russia to come back to the
pathway of bringing in and sustaining
peace so as to bring in its own
contribution to General stability and
well-being
your excellencies
let this one year date
and this suffering of the millions of
people in front of our eyes over the
past year so serve us all a reminder
here in this room that
military Solutions will not put an end
to the war
too many lives have been lost
far too many livelihoods and families
and local communities
Russia can end this aggression
Russia can end the war with it began
Russia must put an end to this hellish
spilling of blood
on on the parties and the International
Community to recommit to the values
principles and purposes of the United
U.N Charter
upholding and preserving our
constitution for we the peoples
must be common interest to all member
states
there is no alternative I thank you
[Music]
I now invite the Secretary General of
the United Nations his Excellency
Antonio will tell us to make a statement
Mr President of General Assembly
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
the one-year Mark of Russia's invasion
of Ukraine stands as a green milestone
for the people of Ukraine and for the
International Community
that invasion is an affront to our
Collective conscience
it is a violation of United Nations
Charter and international law
it is having dramatic humanitarian and
human rights consequences
and the impact is being felt far beyond
Ukraine
as I said from day one Russia's attack
on Ukraine challenges the Cornerstone
principles and values of our
multilateral system
Divine Charter is unambiguous and I
quote
all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use of force against the territorial
Integrity or political independence of
any state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the purposes of the United Nations
Mr President excellencies
the general assembly has addressed in
the clearest terms the attempt by the
Russian Federation to illegally Annex
four regions of Ukraine kerson saporizia
Donetsk and luhansk
in doing so the assembly reaffirmed the
long-standing principles of
international law contained in its
Landmark friendly elections Declaration
of 1970.
namely that and I quote
the territory of a state shall not be
the object of acquisition by another
state
resulting from the threat or user Force
and that no territorial acquisition
shall be recognized as legal
end of quote
the position of the United Nations is
unequivocal
we are committed to the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within its
internationally recognized borders
Mr President
the United Nations
has stayed on the ground working with
humanitarian partners
fully 40 percent of ukrainians are in
need of humanitarian assistance
vital infrastructure has been targeted
water energy and heating systems have
been destroyed in the dead of winter
un agencies have also been cooperating
with host countries that received more
than 8 million ukrainians the largest
Refugee crisis since the Second World
War
last year
the UN launched a
5.6 billion dollar humanitarian appeal
for the people of Ukraine
I urge your full support
I have visited Ukraine twice since the
start of the war
where I heard testimonies of severe
violations of international humanitarian
and human rights laws
in this conflict as elsewhere the United
Nations is committed to ensuring Justice
and the principle of accountability
presidents
even amidst the brutality of War
we have worked in concerted and creative
ways to forge Solutions
in Mario Paul
the United Nations helped evacuate
civilians trapped in the ass of style
still plan
the Black Sea grain initiatives has
shown the possibility of Ukraine and
Russia to advance Global Food security
with the support of government of turkey
and the United Nations
despite ongoing challenges the
initiative to ship grain and other
foodstuffs from Ukraine is making a
difference
we are working hard to remove all
remaining obstacles to the
implementation of the memorandum of
understanding between the Secretariat
and the United Nations and the Russian
Federation
to facilitate exports of Russian foods
and fertilizers to Global markets
this is also an important contribution
to address Global Foods in security
and will continue to support these
initiatives for the benefit of millions
of people across the world especially in
the global South
notwithstanding deep mistrust the
parties to conflict
have also worked out regularly changes
the prisons of War facilitated by
Regional actors
these efforts can and must continue
and expand as much as possible
Mr President
over the past year not only have we seen
suffering and devastating grow
it is also becoming more evident just
how much worse it could all still become
the possible consequences of a spiraling
conflict are a clear and present danger
every day
we are reminded of the Grave threat that
counts us all when irresponsible
military activity continues around the
zaporeitzia nuclear power plant the
largest nuclear facility in Europe
I command the international atomic
energy and the atomic energy agency
for engaging the sides to ensure the
area remains safe
the security and safety of all Ukrainian
nuclear power plants must be guaranteed
the war is also Fanning Regional
instability and fooling Global tensions
and divisions while diverting attention
and resources from other crises and
pressing Global issues
meanwhile we have heard implicit threats
to use nuclear weapons
the so-called tactical use of nuclear
weapons is utterly unacceptable
it is high time to step back from the
brink
complacency will open deepen the crisis
while further evolving our shared
principles proclaimed in the charter
Mr President excellencies war is not the
solution
war is the problem
people in Ukraine are suffering
enormously
ukrainians Russians and people far
beyond need peace
and while prospects may look Bleak today
we must all work
knowing that genuine lasting peace must
be based on the event Charter and
international law
the longer the finding continues the
more difficult this work will be
we don't have a moment to lose and I
thank you
I now give the flow to his Excellency
dmitro culeba Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Ukraine to introduce draft
resolution a slash
es11 L7
Mr President
distinguished Representatives
one year since the Russian Federation
began its full-scale aggression against
Ukraine is approaching
I stood here
at this esteemed place exactly one year
ago
it was February 23rd
24 hours before the aggression began
a massive Russian Force hung over
Ukraine preparing to deal a devastating
blow to my country
and wipe it off the face of the world
map
the first strikes hit the country early
in the morning
ever since then Ukraine exercised its
legitimate right to self-defense
enshrined in the U.N Charter
the Ukrainian people made a choice
fight for their lives
and Against All Odds
we were able to stop the much stronger
aggressor and kick him out of half of
the newly occupied territory of our
country
but even after failing so badly and
losing so many
Russia still wants to destroy Ukraine as
a Sovereign Nation
and no one should be fooled by Russia's
empty calls
for negotiations
the current situation on the front line
proves
they want war
not peace
they are on the attack all along the
front line
from the nipple River
to the Russian border
they keep striking Ukraine's civilian
infrastructure with salvas of crew is
missiles
made in Russia and drones
made in Iran
this is why we have no choice but to
keep fighting for our survival
as any of you would do
the world has seen terrible atrocities
committed by Russians in the occupied
territories
murder of unarmed civilians torture and
rape looting Terror political
persecution
indiscriminate shelling as well as
deliberate attacks on civilian
infrastructure
forcible transfers of and deportations
of thousands of Ukrainian children and
their consequent adoption in Russian
families in order to re-educate them as
Russians
this is a genocide
and this is what we face today
for Ukraine giving up would mean that
such atrocities would be committed all
over our territory
and I'm confident that Any Nation
represented in this chamber
would do the same in our place you would
fight
I know that some still think
and sometimes say
we want to be friends with both Ukraine
and Russia
let it all just end sooner with whatever
result
I can understand that
the problem
is that in this war there are no two
equal sides
there is an aggressor
and a victim
I understand that there are still some
countries that do not want to take
Ukraine's site for various reasons
but it's not about that it's about
taking the side of the United Nations
Charter
it's about taking the side of
international law
it is about taking the side of the U.N
General Assembly resolutions
these are our common rules
and we are all interested in upholding
them
with the exception of the Russian
Federation which thinks that rules do
not apply to it and exist only to be
violated
we are all talking about peace today but
what is peace
the freedom of the occupier to rule over
the land he has ravaged
impunity for war criminals
a respite and a chance to prepare for a
new war and new crimes
we will only worsen the problem if we
replace one ugly reality with another
and call it peace
true peace came in 1945 not because the
forces of good stopped fighting but
because evil was defeated
peace means
Justice
three months ago president walladimir
zielinski outlined our vision for
ensuring comprehensive just and
long-term peace in Ukraine as well as
Global Security the peace formula
this plan is based on 10 points
one
radiation and nuclear safety
two
food security
three energy security
for release of prisoners and deported
persons
five implementation of the UN Charter to
restore territorial sovereignty of
Ukraine within its internationally
recognized borders
six withdrawal of Russian troops and
cessation of hostilities
seven
restoration of Justice including with
the creation of a special Tribunal
eight prevention of echocyte
nine prevention of escalation of war and
repetition of aggression
and 10 confirmation of the end of the
war
this vision is realistic and true to the
facts it covers all areas where peace
needs to be restored
IT addresses the real needs and
challenges faced by the people who
suffer from this war
each of these steps can be implemented
if there is a strong will for peace
among many nations
and if we all unite our efforts around
the same goal
instead of hiding behind the mask of
neutrality let's choose the side of the
U.N Charter and international law
ladies and gentlemen never in recent
history has the line between good and
evil has been so clear
one country
merely wants to live in peace
and I represent that country
the other
wants to kill and destroy and it has its
Representatives too
there is no other country in the world
that wants peace as much as Ukraine does
we never wanted War
we never planned to attack anyone
our troops do not stand on anyone else's
land
we exercise our legitimate right to
self-defense
and do it pretty effectively
we know what we are fighting for
we are defending our land our families
and our homes
can anyone tell what Russians Die For in
a foreign land
this is why calls to cease delivery of
weapons and ammunition to Ukraine are
badly misplaced
it is perfectly legitimate to help a
nation that has been attacked and is
justifiably defending itself
it is an act of defense of the U.N
Charter
it is an act in favor of ending the War
sooner and achieving a lasting and just
peace
on the contrary
it is illegal and against the U.N
Charter to give military help to the
aggressor
it is an act of War escalation and
prolongation of atrocities destruction
and sufferings
the principle of territorial Integrity
cannot be compromised
is there anyone in this room who is
ready to give away one square meter of
its territory to a bloodthirsty neighbor
we all know the answer
there is none
and Ukraine is one of you
the world will drown in chaos if we
allow changing borders by force under
the disguise of political expediency or
sympathy towards aggressor
with the support of the world Ukraine
can restore its territorial integrity
and respect for the U.N Charter and it
will
and this will discourage Russia and
other aggressors from wanting to attack
other nations
to achieve this Noble goal we need to
send a strong and clear message that the
U.N Charter including the principles of
sovereign equality and territorial
Integrity of states
should serve as the basis for the
process of peaceful resolution
I therefore call on members of the
United Nations to support draft
resolution entitled
principles underlying comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine the
aforementioned resolution will
contribute
to our joint efforts
to bring the war to an end as well as
protect the fundamental principles of
international law and the U.N Charter
and again exactly a year ago I was
standing here appealing
to the nation's United in this whole
on the need to prevent War
a year after Against All Odds
Ukraine is effectively defending itself
against a much stronger enemy and I
appeal to you this is a decisive moment
to show support
Unity
and solidarity
this is the moment to prove that you
stand for the U.N Charter in words and
in Deeds
thank you for your attention
[Laughter]
I thank the Minister of Foreign Affairs
of Ukraine
I now give the flow to their
distinguished representative of Belarus
to introduce draft amendments contained
in document a slash es11 L8 and a slash
es11 L9
foreign
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
distinguished colleagues
the Republic of Belarus has the honor
submitting two amendments to the draft
resolution entitled principles of the
charter of the United Nations
underlying a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine
the purpose of these amendments uh
you all have the opportunity to
familiarize yourselves with the
Amendments the objective of the
Amendments is to rectify the
inaccuracies in the text of the draft
resolution
on the topic of the real reasons for the
conflict and we have mentioned that uh
many times for some reason it's not
mentioned here at all to the Genesis of
the conflict not the conflict itself and
also to include into the text important
language
which would ensure that the content of
the resolution is aligned with its title
and would send a powerful signal about
the international communities genuinely
being interested in ending the conflict
in Ukraine as soon as possible the first
amendment's goal is to take the
resolution out of the gray area of half
truths where while still looking for
Great Expressions facts are being
distorted for example the fifth
paragraph of the Preamble is a
describing what is being done by Russia
as a fully fledged Invasion into Ukraine
which in our view is not in line with
reality because if Russia had not
limited itself to just conducting a
special military operation and had
conducted as a resolution says a fully
fledged Invasion especially using
um its full military potential which no
one would wish for if this were the case
I don't think there would be any country
that would be able to exist after that
after several hours or even minutes
after that this is not something that
was ever stated by the leadership of
Russia as a goal of special military
operation we the Republic of Belarus we
believe that the only chance so for
ending the conflict is to immediately
start negotiations with any kind of
preconditions and this was stated on
several occasions basically in in every
statement he makes by the president of
Republic of Belarus Mr LoCash lukashenko
has been doing this throughout the
conflict for about a year now but
nonetheless
reproducing uh once again of this of a
non-consensual operative paragraph five
in the text only takes us further away
from the goal of attaining Peace the
security council meeting on the 17th of
February this year the Republic of
Belarus quoted a former heads of
governments and states of Normandy four
who recently publicly and voluntarily
acknowledged that from the very
beginning they were not interested in
peace in Ukraine at the time when
they're working on the agreements
contained in the Minsk 2 package and
this was in February 2015. we think that
lying in the course on negotiations on a
peaceful resolution especially at such a
level is completely unacceptable and we
are convinced that the general assembly
is too condemned with the responsible
acts of those politicians who've played
as such a specific role in creating the
preconditions for the current conflict
the Second Amendment we are submitting
has the goal of including into the text
the major elements needed for a peaceful
settlement
we think that it's either a tragic
oversight by the proponents and
co-sponsors of the resolution or it is
intentional
an intentional step that they undertook
that the drafter resolution which is
aimed at comprehensive just and Lasting
peace and in Ukraine has does not
contain an appeal to holding peace
negotiations
the Republic of Belarus has been calling
for it since the very first days of the
conflict
or even along prior to the conflict we
have been we have been saying the same
thing let me just simply remind you here
that it is thanks to the efforts made by
the president of the Republic of Belarus
in February and March 2022 it was
possible to organize several rounds of
negotiations between cave and Moscow in
Belarus and this at the time gave us all
reason for cautious optimism now
breaking these negotiations down as well
as the continuous pumping of uh Ukraine
with Weaponry
resulted in protracting the
confrontation this in turn leads to the
escalation of military activities new
victims and also delays the prospects of
Peace in Ukraine we're equally concerned
by the irresponsible statements made by
individual politicians about their
Readiness to provide Ukraine with lethal
Weaponry up to and including weapons of
mass destruction if these plans are to
be implemented this would inevit
inevitably lead to a news a spiral of
escalation
countless victims and a very real
Prospect of a global con conflict this
is not something we can allow to happen
and this is precisely what the objective
our amendment is the Amendments we are
submitting
have no hidden agenda and we genuinely
think that their goal is to end the
conflict as soon as possible using
peaceful means but voting upon these
amendments we will consider as a test of
being truly interested in attaining a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine I thank you for your attention
I thank the distinguished representative
of Belarus
I now give the floor to the district
representative of the Russian Federation
Mr President
a little uh more than a year ago Ukraine
and it's a western sponsors convene the
11th emergency special session of the
general assembly at the time many of the
United Nations members states were
disoriented and yielded to the
collective West which
what's claiming that nothing more
terrible had happened in the history of
humankind and that is why the reaction
to What was being done by Russia was to
be unprecedented since that many of you
have better understood the reasons for
what happened and what is happening now
and it's become much more difficult for
the Western uh Camp to mobilize member
states of the UN in support of their
Crusade against Russia and this is also
shown in the emptied out draft
resolution that we have which
nonetheless remains anti-russia and
harmful and I will revert to this topic
later it's just that the chance of
getting support for something more
substantive given that member states are
much better informed now are far far
fewer and our opponents what they need
first and foremost now are numbers and
voices
so let me sum up and talk about what is
it that member states have found out
about Western thinking and how our world
has changed over time well first of all
it became obvious that the aim the main
element of anti-russia propaganda
campaign conducted by our former Western
Partners consists of
accusing Russia of unprovoked aggression
against its neighbor which is a result
of Imperial Ambitions and the desire to
take hold of foreign territory and
destroyed Ukraine Ukraine as such now
believing these absurges is only
possible if you forget about the eight
years which preceded our special
military operations
and this is how long the criminal
nationalist regime which arrived in cave
as a result of an Institutional coup
supported by the West that's how long
they they kept a waging bloody war
against the people in donbas and their
own
um crime was that they wanted to remain
Russian they wanted to see their
children as Russian to they wanted to
honor the memory of their ancestors and
did not want want to glorify Nazis and
their acolytes starting history on the
24th of 2022 and ignoring everything
that came before is an intentional
attempt by the collective West to
confuse people and hide the real reasons
for the conflict whereas they are key
for understanding the prospects for its
peaceful settlement
to a very well known confession
Confessions of a number of retired
Western leaders no one has any doubt
today that
the West used the cover of the music
agreement approved by the security
Council whereas in actual fact that have
the goal of preparing Ukraine for war
against our country with the condoning
and participation of Americans and
Europeans in Kiev what you had is a the
formation and the Armament of a truly
Authority authoritarian despotic regime
which kept
destroying all of its opposition or
anything that could be in any way
connected to Russia in a country when
where a Russian is a native tongue for
most people and which for many centuries
was culturally United with our country
pursuing a policy like this meant
destroying the foundations of society
and installing an artificial Paradigm of
Ukraine is anti-russia throughout all of
these years the key of regime continued
it's inhuman shelling of the peaceful
towns in Donetsk and luhansk People's
Republic were peoples peaceful civilians
were dying including children and we
regularly informed the security Council
and general assembly about that
we conducted meetings and sessions
within the U.N in which people from Don
boss themselves participated and they
had the opportunity there to describe
their tragedy and those who followed
those meetings understand very well that
we had no other option no option rather
than defending the people of donbass and
ensuring the Safety and Security of our
country using military means in other
words we started the special military
operation so as to stop the eight year
long work by by by Kiev against the
people in Donetsk and lugansk we had
warned that it's unacceptable to have
the military presence of collective West
in the territory of neighbor
neighborly Ukraine this was a direct
threads to our national security about
the West has on many times brazenly
ignored our concerns and continue
bringing the military infrastructure of
NATO closer and closer to our borders
the statements made by a number of
countries that Russia is guilty of
destroying Regional and Global security
systems are hypocritical our Western
colleagues now prefer not to recall that
but at the end of 2021 Russia put forth
a whole number of specific initiatives
on de-escalation and
strengthening confidence in your the
Atlantic area we proposed that the U.S
and NATO sign security guarantees
treaties we therefore were thus giving
diplomacy a chance but this chance was
arrogantly spurned by the United States
and their allies they outright refused
to even discuss our initiatives which if
they had been realized would have
enabled us to avoid what we're
witnessing today and we understand now
why that was the case when we suggested
that we reach an agreement on security
guarantees the West at the time was
already going full steam ahead to turn
Ukraine into a fully fledged military
platform immediately next to our borders
now remembering that do we have any
reason to trust the statements being
made by Western representative today
when they say that they want peace I
think that today one year after the
active stage of the Ukrainian crisis
Crisis began very few doubt that it's
not Ukraine
that is fighting Russia because Ukraine
basically spent all of its military
potential in the first weeks of the
special military operation but rather it
is a collective West in the prison of
the United States and it's NATO and
European Union allies not only do they
provide Kiev with weapons and ammunition
they also provide the armed towards of
Ukraine with intelligence information
and coordinate their missile strikes at
the same time West they used to tell us
tall tales about partnership and
cooperation has now fully shown its true
colors all decorum is set aside and the
goal is now is to arm Ukraine and thus
inflict strategic defeat on my country
to dismember and destroy it
such schemes are being openly discussed
in a number of Eastern European capitals
in the European Parliament and the
slogans to this effect are being
promoted in European and by European
American politicians for this goal the
West is closing its eyes to the
resurging neo-nazism in Ukraine into the
glorification of Nazi criminals it's
becoming very clear that the Ukrainian
crisis has only become a catalyst for
the visceral russophobia to come to the
surface it has now contaminated the
American and European Elites they're
competing against each other and the
number of sanctions and impose on my
country whereas these sanctions in
actual fact I'm hitting the developing
world hardest
in this desire of theirs to defeat
Russia in any way possible they can
sacrifice not just Ukraine they're ready
to plunge the world entire into the
abyss of War what is at stake after all
is keeping the United States and its
allies hegemony they don't want to have
anyone come to the level of governing
the planet they think it's their Turf as
Mr Burrell stated they are a one in a
wonderful garden and the rest is just
the jungle now the appeals to stop by
the very word developing States is
something that the collective West does
not react to any peace plan
in quotes which is being introduced by
either Kiev or its Western sponsors is
an actual fact can boil down to the same
same thing the capitulation of Russia it
has become obvious to everyone a long
time ago and the real attitude of the
key of regime negotiations is shown by
the law passed by the Ukrainian
president in September last year the law
bans negotiating with the Russian
leadership
thanks to the revelations of the former
Israeli Prime Minister naftali Bennett
no one doubts that in the march of last
year when our special military operation
was in its very early stages of the
zelinsky regime under pressure from its
Western Masters
withdrew
their own ideas on long-term peace with
Russia under pressure from West
and this would have enabled us to remove
the reasons which made us start the um
special military operation Washington
London and Brussels did not arm and
strengthen the Kiev regime made Ukraine
into Russia so Russia and Ukraine can
once again live in peace and security
this is a logic of the colonizer and
pitting neighbors against each other
this is well known to our African and
Asian Partners there's nothing new in
the western Arsenal that appeared since
then so what can we see today as a
result of all of this what we see is the
Ukrainian crisis which is in
conflagration is being fueled by by the
west through their Weaponry they are
conducting a hybrid War down to the last
Ukrainian and behind this not just the
politicians with their fantasies about
defeating Russia on the battlefield but
rather the greedy greedy weapons Lobby
they're getting their super profits and
a perfect place to test their our
ammunitions and and weapons in military
conditions but the involvement of the
West in in a conflict from
um indirect it's becoming more and more
direct and with noticeable consequences
and it ranges from the food and energy
crisis which was provoked by the Western
sanctions to undermining the north
stream for which of course the
perpetrators will have to be held
accountable what we also have is this
suffering people of Ukraine because
they're being used by the cave regime as
Canon
father for the purpose of Western
geopolitical goals those of the
ukrainians who end up in the west become
a service without any rights and they're
in the service of the western Masters
they are subjected to violence and
exploitation and
and that is why most of them despite the
Rabid russophobic propaganda are saving
themselves from them from hostilities in
Russia with the Ukrainian people are
loved and respected as regards my
country to reconsider all of this as our
war with Russia for survival for the
future of our country our children and
our identity this is a war which as was
also the case 80 years ago
was uh um in which a treacherous and
Powerful enemies involved who wants to
take over our land and subjugate us and
the russophobia the um appeals to
dismember our country the German tanks
once again going to kill Russians the
goals to put red stars on the weapons of
those who do not want to give up on
their Russian identity only strengthen
this impression and this is a plan that
came into Implement tension not now but
already in 2014 where on our borders we
had a regime which is hostile to us and
it was being strengthened and Ukraine in
all of this is nothing more than just a
pawn
and since that is the case well you will
understand very well then looking for
Solutions out of this situation so a
fraught with most negative consequences
for the humankind as a whole in the case
of direct confrontation between Russia
and Nita the NATO needs to be conducted
not between Russia and Ukraine but
between Russia and the collective West
first and foremost Washington Washington
which is behind the key of regime we are
ready for a search for serious and
long-term diplomatic solution we have
stated this on many occasions our
opponents have not yet recovered from
their futile illusions that they could
defeat a nuclear power and that is why
removing the reasons underpin
underpinning the special military
operation a year ago is something that
we need to do using military means next
and last question how can U.N member
states help move to the peaceful
resolution of the difference between
Russia and West we can say one thing for
certain the resolution which is
submitted
here and will be put to the vote will
not help this at all it will rather
encourage the West in their acts and
give our opponents the pretext to state
that Russia is supposedly isolated in
the world and that would mean that they
will continue their militaristic
russophobic line using the supposed
support of U.N member states as a cover
of course the resolution will be used by
the key of regime as well in their
propaganda and this is already being
done yesterday already Mr zielinski
stated that the general assembly is
being convened so as to pass a
resolution in support of his and
Infamous peace plan which consists of 10
items and this when we know that the
mention of this confusing initiative as
far as we understand was removed from
the draft at the request of a number of
U.N colleagues unfortunately the key of
regime is incorrigible in how
disingenuous they are but this
disingenuousness that we are well
familiar with simply don't know about
now can this situation be rectified can
we prevent the west from using this
document for their purposes especially
in the conditions where many of you
under severe pressure and blackmail from
Washington and allies yes it's possible
what you need to do is support the
balancing amendments that my Belarus
colleague had introduced right before me
if the amendments are rejected and the
document will remain as it is now
one-sided and divorced divorced from
reality we urge everyone to vote against
the draft resolution I thank you
I think the distance representative of
the Russian Federation
I now now give the floor to the this his
Excellency
Joseph Borel fontellis
High representative for European Affairs
and security policy vice president or
the of the European Commission
[Music]
foreign
the general assembly
distinguished delegates
ladies and gentlemen
this week's marks one year since Russia
started its legal invasion of Ukraine
everybody knows
this was our remained a clear-cut case
of an aggression by a permanent member
of the security Council
and this is Russia
everybody knows
a blatant violation of international law
and the principles of the United Charter
the world needs peace in Ukraine
and the people of Ukraine deserve peace
after so much suffering
but not just any peace
we need a piece grounded in the
principles of the United Nations chart
that's why we are
In This Very whole
this is what the resolution presented by
Ukraine is about
it's about to reiterate our support for
Ukraine
and to set out the principles for peace
I want to stress it
this war
again Ukraine is not and it will be an
issue
it's not about the West versus Russia
no this illegal War
concerns everyone the north the South
the East the West the whole world
and we are here today to reiterate our
support to the Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial Integrity within its
International recognized borders
as for any member of the United Nations
yes sovereignty to return your integrity
these are the principles
that Russia is attacking in Ukraine
every day
these are also the principles we have to
uphold
everywhere
every day
and if we don't condemn and stop
Russia's actions in Ukraine today
visually increase to risk for any other
country
elsewhere in the world
to face a similar aggression
no one can feel safe in a world
where the illegal use of force
would be normalized
and there it is the article 51 of United
Charter
Ukraine has the inherent right to defend
itself
just like any other United Nations
member
Ukraine has the right to defend itself
and protect its population against the
daily shelling by the Russian army
excellencies click
the European Union has always been a
peace project
and we have been quite successful on
bringing peace to the European continent
and promoting it around the world
it is Central to our our DNA
is in our origin
and when it comes to Ukraine
the real question today are what kind of
Peace yes peace but what kind of Peace
yes and the war but how do we end the
war
how how to achieve this space
the first obvious step for peace
is for Russia to stop its attack
it must end all hostilities
and withdraw its forces and military
equipment for Ukrainian soil
and he must do it immediately completely
and unconditionally
and until then
European Union will continue to give
Ukraine the support it needs to defend
its population it's also in accordance
with United Nations Charter
we will continue to provide humanitarian
and financial assistance
we will work to hold Russia accountable
for its actions and war crimes
and we know from experience
that there can be no lasting peace
without accountability
at the same time
we will continue to support Ukraine's
wish for a Justice in line with the
United Nations Charter
to
two tracks through two tracks
supporting Ukraine are looking for peace
they go hand in hand
they are not
either or
they are not incompatible by the country
they go hand in hand they are
complementary
you'll know about President zelensky
peace formula
European Union supported
and we will work to mobilize the
broadest possible international support
for it
indeed all of us
all of us have a responsibility to work
for a just a lasting peace
as this resolution table by Ukraine sets
out
and the United Nations Secretary General
has offered his good offices
to bring an end to this war
and we support him
others have also contributed to the
Diplomatic efforts
the purpose of this resolution is to
support and encourage the efforts to
look for peace
we European Union we have been working
in close cooperation with Ukrainian
partners
throughout the whole Preparatory process
in a transparent and inclusive manner
we have been as inclusive as transparent
as possible
amendments and comments made in good
faith were duly considerate and taken on
board to the extent possible
and we thank the allegations that engage
with us
this for sure has a strengthened the
text
but
by putting forward additional amendments
right now
Belarus tries to create confusion on the
process
when the text before the membership is a
simple call for peace in line with
United Nations Charter
these amendments are not made in good
faith
they are manipulative
since they do not reflect the situation
on the ground
which is the unjustified and unprovoked
aggression by Young member State against
another
we will vote
against these amendments
and call on our United Nations member
states to do the same and to support the
draft resolution table by Ukraine
excellencies distinguished delegates the
text before us today
is very much in line with United Nations
Secretary General Lee at his briefing to
the general assembly on the 6th of
February
and even today on his speech
asked rightly put it
the world needs peace
but peace in line with the United
Nations Charter and international law
and for all reasons simple reasons
evident reasons
I'd ask you to join us in co-sponsoring
this United Nations General Assembly
resolution
and a vote in favor
because this is a moment for every
member of the United Nations to stand
and to be counted
thank you
[Music]
I thank the vice president of the
European Commission
now I give the flow to the to his
Excellency Antonio
Deputy Prime Minister and Minister of
Foreign Affairs and international
cooperation of Italy
Mr President
excellences
a year ago
the Russian army invaded Ukraine
an invasion that led to tens of
thousands of deaths
that led to the destruction of
infrastructure
led to
unbelievable disasters
due to an illegal invasion
violating the rules of international law
we are standing alongside the ukrainians
who are suffering at the moment
it's been very clear
the ongoing migration is a violation
of the United Nations Charter against
International Security and stability
no country can be safe
if the violation of our common
principles and rules remains an
accountant for
on this anniversary Ukraine is still
stands and we stand in full solidarity
with the country and its people
there is attached to their leaves and to
critical infrastructure with devastating
humanitarian costs are inaccessible they
must stop
but we want to work in favor peace
ladies and gentlemen there is no peace
without justice justice is integrity
freedom
Independence for Ukraine
there is no peace without Justice
stands for agreements on specific issues
such as the establishment of a nuclear
safe area around the region
and the renewal of the black
sea grain initiative
unnecessary a Dodge response on these
threats and the important steps toward
building Mutual trust and laying the
foundations
of a wider wider dialogue
a comprehensive just a lasting piece in
line with the principle of the charter
of the United Nations is needed as the
resolution brought to the attention of
this element emergency special session
clearly states now more than ever
we need diplomacy also to take in
account of the legitimate concerns and
the expectation of the countries of the
global South which are bearing the
consequences of this conflict
Italy is ready to do its part in this
direction
now is the time to redouble our
Collective support for diplomatic
efforts to achieve this goal
today in this world Parliament where all
the states are represented as equal we
have the opportunity and the moral duty
to demonstrate that we can work together
to achieve this goal adopting a
resolution for peace
with a wet majority
today we are called Ubuntu defend the
rules-based international order
the United Nations
and in this moment in the general
assembly are at the Forefront for peace
and security and human rights
for this reason Italy is a proud
co-sponsor of this draft resolution and
decal on the member states to support a
just Peace by voting yes
the resolution and vote in favor of the
resolution
I thank the Deputy Prime Minister of
Italy
and now I give the flow
to the to her extensive Linda Thomas
Greenfield permanent representative of
the United of the United States to the
United Nations
member of the cabinet of the president
of the United States
thank you Mr President
thank you to the Secretary General
colleagues
today we are gathered to discuss an
important historic resolution
one that will promote diplomacy
dialogue and a lasting peace in Ukraine
the timing of this moment is of course
intentional
one year ago
Russia launched its illegal unprovoked
full-scale Invasion into Ukraine
I remember that day clearly as I know
all of you do too as well
that evening I walked into the United
Nations security Council for an
emergency meeting which the United
States had called for because we
believed that Russia's invasion of
Ukraine was imminent
at this point we had been sounding the
alarm bells for weeks
I had informed the council in no
uncertain terms about the buildup of
troops along the border and what we
thought it meant
secretary blinken had also come to the
security Council and laid out in detail
secretary blink had also come to the
what we expected would soon unfold
a few days before the invasion
Russia's Deputy foreign minister told us
to and I quote
stop the Hysteria
on the very night of Russia's Invasion
into Ukraine Russia's representative
said in the security Council that and I
quote occupation of Ukraine is not in
our plan
all Russia did was deny deny deny as we
have heard the Russian PR due again
today
that cold February night one year ago
today I asked Russia to stop
to return to its borders to send its
troops tanks and planes back into their
barracks and hangars to send diplomats
back to the negotiating table
but it was too late
at that exact moment
I joined so many others in the security
Council and around the world to make a
plea
in making a plea for peace
President Putin chose War
this was an illegal unprovoked attack on
Ukraine
but it was also an assault on the United
Nations it struck at the very heart
of the U.N Charter
we all know what happened next and what
is still happening now
the bombing of kindergartens and high
schools
and hospitals the Slaughters of innocent
civilians the worst Refugee crisis in
Europe since World War II an
unprecedented hunger crisis around the
world
threats to nuclear and energy security
families forcibly separated Ukrainian
children relocated to Russia Mass
suffering
crimes against humanity
colleagues this vote is a moment to
remember why we are here of course I
cannot speak for all of you I can only
speak for myself
when I was sworn in for this role it was
exactly one year to the day of Russia's
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
back then I could not have known the
existential threat that the U.N Charter
would face
but I did know what President Biden and
the American people were sending me here
to do
to represent my country to the world yes
but also to uphold the U.N Charter to
engage in dialogue and diplomacy and to
lead us toward a more peaceful more
prosperous planet and that is what I'm
here to do today
and no matter what else you were sent
here to do I know we all share these
same goals in common to represent our
countries to advocate for diplomacy and
to push for peace
this vote is an opportunity to do just
that
we have before us a resolution that
calls on the nations of the world to
support diplomatic efforts to achieve a
comprehensive and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
a piece consistent with the UN Charter
consistent with its fundamental
principles of sovereignty territorial
integrity and self-defense
colleagues this vote will go down in
history
on the one-year anniversary of this
conflict we will see where the nations
of the world stand on the matter of
Peace in Ukraine
earlier this week President Biden
visited Ukraine and he made it clear
where the United States stands
he stood shoulder to shoulder with
president zielinski to remind the world
that one year later
he still stands
Ukraine still stands and America still
stands with Ukraine
I too visited Ukraine late last year and
while I learned a great deal in my
meetings and discussions the most
powerful lessons I took away were in the
faces of the Ukrainian people
and president zielinski I saw resolve I
saw a leader determined to defend his
people and defend his country for as
long as it takes
in the faces of refugees and victims
I saw suffering
deep sorrow
unimaginable pain was etched into their
visages
it is hard to overstate how much
unnecessary anguish and pain President
Putin has caused
but it was in the faces of Ukrainian
children where I found Hope
I met a 10 year old girl Milena who
lived in a facility where displaced
families were gathering to prepare for
the cold winter a facility that had once
been hit by Russian missiles
and I asked Melina what she wanted to do
when the war was over
and she smiled
she told me simply that she wanted to go
back to school and see her best friend
again
her face beamed with hope
I will never forget her shining eyes
colleagues we should never give up on
hope we should never give up on the
potential for diplomacy or the power of
dialogue or the urgency of peace
we now have an opportunity to vote for
that peace and to vote to uphold the U.N
Charter once more
a U.N Charter which stands for
sovereignty and territorial integrity a
U.N Charter that stands for the inherent
right of self-defense
and a U.N Charter which aims to maintain
International Peace and security and end
the scourge of War
so colleagues I urge you to vote against
against any and all hostile amendments
that seek to undermine the U.N Charter
and ignore the truth of this War I urge
you instead
to vote Yes in support of this
resolution as it stands to promote
diplomacy and dialogue
yes diplomacy and dialogue to promote
cooperation on the threats to Global
Food security energy Finance the
environment nuclear security and safety
to defend the U.N Charter we have all
signed up to protect and to support a
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine thank
you very much
[Music]
I thank the distinguished member of the
cabinet of the president of the United
States
and now I give the Flow To Her
Excellency Melanie Jolie Minister
Foreign Affairs of Canada
is
foreign
as equal members of the general assembly
to once again reaffirm her full support
for the purposes and principles of the
charter of the United Nations
to ensure that these purposes and
principles underlie a comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
and to affirm our support for
international law
and for accountability when the law is
broken
we have before us today a resolution
that does this
its text has been drafted to reflect the
views and concerns of members from all
regions
for these reasons Canada believes that
this draft resolution deserves the
support of each and every member of this
assembly
Mr President
as we mark this Grim occasion
the Russians Federation further Invasion
an illegal war of aggression against
Ukraine rages is on
Russia is continuing its missile attacks
against Ukrainian cities killing
Ukrainian civilians and destroying the
country's critical infrastructure
schools and hospitals have not been
spared thousands of Ukrainian civilians
have been killed more have been injured
and more than 14 million ukrainians have
been forced to flee their homes
last week I was in Kiev
and I heard firsthand some of the
heartbreaking choices this war has
forced on the people of Ukraine
these stories remind us of the true and
brutal nature of Russia's War
this is not and has never been a
so-called special military operation
President Putin is entirely responsible
for this war
and his latest address proves that he
remains unmoored from this reality
his address was nothing more than
recycled absurdities as repeated by the
Russian Ambassador today in this chamber
and his suspension of the start treaty
is nothing short of Reckless
this is total war aimed at punishing and
destroying the free and dependent and
Sovereign Nation of Ukraine and its
people
and President Putin will not succeed
Mr President
the resistance
foreign
we know that for reconstruction to be
inclusive and enduring it must address
both the physical and invisible impacts
of Putin's War
and so we must tackle the psychological
marks of the war on Ukraine's people
with the same seriousness and urgency as
the physical scars
the impacts of the war on food and
energy security supply chains and
inflation have rippled across every
corner of the world and have hit the
most vulnerable the hardest
Russia's war of choice is estimated to
cost the global economy 2.8 trillion
dollars
51 million more people were pushed into
poverty during the first three months of
the war alone because of the soaring
food and energy prices triggered by
Russia's invasion
these are lives and livelihoods
destroyed by President Putin's war of
choice and its impacts
and we have heard the calls from many
countries here in this chamber about the
disastrous impacts of this war on their
peoples and their economies
but peace has to be built on security
and justice
and Russia needs to listen and respond
to the demands of this assembly to stop
its war of aggression
please
politics
the lady Palm dance
the unity
is
a territorial
Ukraine
immediately foreign
words and actions Russia is showing us
very plainly
that it does not respect this assembly
and the members represented here
more than that it has expanded its
illegal war of aggression
it has used its veto its power
its privilege to sideline the security
Council
it has attempted to legally Annex
Ukraine's territory through shamra
faranda
it has pedal misinformation and
conspiracy theories online in our
countries and in this chamber
it has DoubleDown on its attacks against
Ukraine's critical infrastructure in
clear violation of international
humanitarian law
this is not the sign of a country that
respects its obligation or its fellow
member states
Russia would have you believe that this
is about forcing you to choose sides
today's vote
is not about choosing sides
it's about choosing peace a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine it is about choosing to uphold
the U.N Charter
it is about respecting the right of
every state in this chamber to chart
their own future
it is about choosing rules over chaos
and clearly stating that no one today
and in the future can this regard the
principles of sovereignty and
territorial integrity
Canada encourages every member of this
assembly to choose peace and vote in
favor of this resolution thank you so
much
I thank the distinguished minister of
Canada
now I give the flow to his Excellency
Jose Manuel Alvarez Bueno Minister
Foreign Affairs European union and
cooperation of Spain
Senor president
[Music]
foreign
a world that is more insecure and more
viable
session is of particularly
to base ourselves
foreign
my country and we have committed 250
million euros for the Reconstruction of
Ukraine through multilateral agencies
forgetting the needs of other partners
such as
Latin America we're not reducing we are
increasing our cooperation budget for
these areas
Global consequences
the financial crisis and the energy
crisis following the pandemics
the worst humanitarian situations
and the sovereign
thank you very much
I thank the distinguished minister of
Spain
and now I give the flow to the to his
Excellency mariju Adolfo Bokaro Flores
Minister Foreign Affairs of Guatemala
senior president Mr President
excellences
I had the opportunity to be in case
I proved that this war has produced
for this invitation to the resumed 11
special session of the general assembly
of the United Nations
Federation against Ukraine
um
foreign
aim to create a special a tribunal on
the crime of aggression committed by
Russia against international law in
accordance with International students
Mr President we are appalled terrible
humanitarian consequences of Human
Rights consequences caused by the
hostilities against Ukraine
devastating consequences for the
civilian populations cannot be tolerated
today all of us with the effects
and we firmly believe that this is
essential to fully respect the
obligations that we have under
International humanitarian law that aims
to protect this civilian population as
well as guaranteed humanitarian access
to this secure in order to guarantee
that all attacks
foreign
thank you
I thank the distinguished minister of
Guatemala and now I give the flow to
Hurricane
Minister of Foreign and European Affairs
of Slovenia
president of the general assembly
Secretary General excellencies ladies
and gentlemen
in 1945 the United Nations were created
to save succeeding Generations from the
scourge of War
you and Charlie reflected our Collective
woe to refrain from the use of Armed
Force against the territorial Integrity
or political independence of any state
aggression violation of territorial
integrity and illegal annexation of
sovereign territories should have no
place in the world order of the 21st
Century
yet the principles Insurance in the U.N
Charter are being blatantly violated and
all those who hoped for a peaceful just
and prosperous World almost eight
decades ago would have been deeply
disappointed
ladies and gentlemen a year ago Ukraine
a sovereign country was attacked by its
neighbor the Russian Federation
sadly despite the Wide International
condemnation and calls for the immediate
withdrawal the war still continues along
with its devastating consequences
especially for the civilian population
I commence the bravery and courage of
the Ukrainian people
Slovenia knows from its own historical
experience what it means to fight for
your land
we know what is at stake when somebody
uses Force to deny your Independence and
sovereignty
and although we slovenians are deeply
concerned about the wider security
political and Economic Consequences of
the Russian aggression we also remain
committed to assisting Ukraine and its
people
we stand in solidarity with the women
men and children whose lives have been
changed Forever by this unjustified War
we are deeply concerned about growing
numbers of Civilian casualties and the
growth and testimonies of sexual and
gender-based violence used as a weapon
of War
especially heartbreaking are the
accounts from children
millions are displaced many of them at
risk of human trafficking exploitation
conflict related sexual violence and
forced deportations
they are deeply traumatized by the war
and the violence their childhood is over
forever
the deliberate attacks of the Russian
army on civilian population and critical
infrastructure constitute most serious
crimes that should not go unpunished all
those responsible must be held to
account
Slovenia supports all efforts to end
impunity for the perpetrators of
international law violations especially
the most serious ones
the principle of accountability must be
upheld since it is the only foundation
for the life when the war and its
atrocities end
it is the only foundation of Justice the
only foundation for reconciliation and
the only foundation which enables the
victims to move forward excellencies
our strong support goes to the efforts
by the U.N Secretary General as well as
the member states that promote a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
we need to redouble our diplomatic
efforts to de-escalate the current
situation and end the fighting through
political dialogue negotiation and other
peaceful means
all peace efforts which take into
account who is the aggressor and who is
its victim deserve our support
Slovenia would like to stress that
International or peaceful settlement of
disputes and the respect for the
decisions of international tribunals as
well as their full implementation are
the building blocks of a world that is
peaceful stable and prosperous
Mr President this war reminds us all
just how globally connected and
interdependent we are its consequences
are felt all over the world
and I would like to State this very
clearly these are not consequences of
our support for Ukraine no consequences
of our reaction to the illegal
aggression these are the consequences of
the aggression itself the the soul and
full responsibility of the aggressor
with a staggering rice in food and
energy prices and the looming inflation
millions of people are faced with severe
challenges disruptions to food supply
chains energy and finance systems around
the globe affect us all
but the leaves developed and low-income
countries suffer the most and we all
must do better
I would like to reassure our friends and
partners worldwide that reacting to the
Russian aggression on Ukraine does not
mean that the other conflicts crisis or
challenges are forgotten
a humanitarian response to other
situations of need is not being
diminished our solidarity and
responsibility remain firm
we applaud Ukraine for launching the
initiative grain from kirane despite the
war Ukraine extended its hand across the
sea to the people in need and those
facing food insecurity
to facilitate the grain exports Slovenia
has joined efforts to help and support
this important initiative with its own
contribution
ladies and gentlemen
let me conclude by saying it once more
any unprovoked invasion of any sovereign
country is unacceptable
violations of the international legal
order that we have worked so hard to
build cannot and must not become our new
normal
with that
Slovenia gives its strong support for
today's resolution on principles
underlying a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine in line with
the U.N Charter thank you
I thank the distinguished minister of
Slovenia
now I give the flow to his Excellency
Minister of Foreign Affairs of Estonia
Mr President Excellence is ladies and
gentlemen
a year ago
the world watched in horror how Russia
launched its full-scale brutal
unprovoked and illegal war of aggression
against Ukraine
and let remind that Russia has hold war
against Ukraine for almost nine years
a permanent member of the security
Council whose mandate in that seat is
rightfully under challenge
demonstrated its complete disrespect for
the rules-based international order
by invading its Sovereign neighbor
Ukraine Russia has trampled upon the
fundamental principles of the U.N
Charter including the obligation to
refrain from using Force against another
state
Russia has completely ignored several
calls by the general assembly to stop
its aggression and the legally binding
order of the icj from last March to
suspend immediately its military
operation as they call in Ukraine
there have been no signs of
de-escalation and we see the opposite as
Russia's new offensive is unfolding
Russia continues to punish Ukraine for
choosing its own Sovereign path
as we speak Russian bombs continue
targeting critical infrastructure
including energy and water systems with
the aim of breaking the Ukrainian will
by causing immense pain and suffering to
civilians we have witnessed Russia's
massive air strikes on civilian sites
often intensely populated areas
abounding evidence shows that the
aggressor has also used sexual and
gender-based violence as a weapon of War
this brutal war of aggression has
already caused at least 19
000 civilian casualties approximately
1300 of them children
nearly 13 and a half million people have
had to flee the homes while entire
cities have been reduced to Rubble over
17 million people in Ukraine are in need
of humanitarian assistance over 1.6
million ukrainians have been deported
among them thousands of children for
illegal adoptions
truth of that should prevail
therefore I call on countries worldwide
to recognize Russia's war of aggression
against Ukraine as a genocide
Putin has not kept secret
about his intent to annihilate Ukrainian
nation and State
let us be clear Russia's full-scale war
of aggression impacts us all and
therefore it is our duty to restore
peace and Justice and not let the
aggressor go unpunished
aggression as an instrument of
international relations must be
completely discredited Russia must be
held accountable for all atrocity crimes
committed in Ukraine including for the
crime of aggression for this we need to
establish of an international special
tribunal to hold Russian political
military leadership to account the U.N
can protect the common values of states
enshrined in the u.n's charter by
denying Mr Putin the opportunity to hide
in the judicial loophole as we know
impunity today will only lead to more
crimes tomorrow
so Mr Putin
you will be on the tribunal and pay for
crimes
you have done
Putin
must be Mr president
Ukraine deserves peace
peace that preserves Ukraine's
territorial integrity and upholds its
sovereignty in accordance with you and
Charter and international law
towards a comprehensive just and Lasting
power
peace is the immediate
complete and unconditional withdrawal of
the occupying forces of the Russian
Federation from the territory of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
the use of force to redraw National
borders cannot be an option A call upon
the International Community to support
the 10-point peace plan put forward by
Ukraine and commit to working together
towards its implementation today's
resolution is an important building
block on this path its International
Community will not stop the Russian
aggression the global impact of the war
on food Security Financial system energy
and environment will become even more
devastating
to stop that victim State also needs
power to defend
Estonia has given one percent of its GDP
to military aid
help Ukraine to defend itself
the president February 24th is a
symbolic
date for the students we celebrate the
anniversary of the student Declaration
of Independence
from 1918. last year's anniversary
reminded Us in the most brutal manner of
fragile Independence and freedom can be
on behalf of the Estonian people I want
to pay tribute to the immeasurable
resolve and resilience of Ukrainian
people they are not only defending the
country and people but also our common
values International legal order and the
U.N Charter
it is our duty as humans
to keep standing behind Ukraine
in my
visits last year to Ukraine
I can say that ukrainians are truly a
bravest people
on Earth their colleagues righteous
destructive and genocidal war of
aggression that is fueled by their
imperialist Ambitions has to be stopped
therefore Estonia votes for the U.N
General Assembly resolution principles
underlying a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine and I Call On
The World un Community to do the same
slavo crani
I think the minister for foreign affairs
of Estonia and I now give the floor to
his Excellency Elia darcheshvili
Minister for foreign affairs of Georgia
Mr President
Excellence is
ladies and gentlemen
the United Nations was founded to save
succeeding Generations from this scratch
a war unfortunately this course has been
repeatedly challenged
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine has been a Brazen attack on the
entire International rules-based order
shattering Global Peace and security
architecture it has resulted in grave
humanitarian consequences loss of lives
and mass displacement after one year we
gathered again to stand for the
principles of the charter this
organization is founded on for the
fundamental norms and principles of the
international law dear colleagues it has
been almost 15 years since Russia's
full-scale military aggression against
Georgia and the consequent occupation of
20 of its territories in blatant
violation of the principles of the U.N
Charter Helsinki final Act and the
chapter of Paris Russia occupied aprasia
and srinivale regions of Georgia remain
in the constant source of insecurity due
to Russia's illegal stations military
basis
excellencies Georgia remains committed
to peaceful resolution of Russia Georgia
conflict that relies on the occupation
of two Georgian regions by Russia on the
one hand and Reconciliation and
confidence building between the
communities across the occupation lines
on the other
while Georgia remains in full compliance
with the EU mediated 12 August 2008
ceasefire agreements Consolidated
approach of the International Community
is essential in urging Russia to comply
with its obligations and the ceasefire
agreements and withdraw its military
forces from the territory of Georgia in
this regard Georgia tries to utilize the
existing negotiations formats of the
Geneva and the national discussions dear
colleagues Ukraine needs peace our
countries and our people need peace the
world needs peace we Face the global
challenges of unprecedented scale
climate change natural disasters
pandemics terrorism and conventional
threats that require our joint efforts
our cooperation
there is so much the United Nations can
and have to do we need to do so for our
children and we need to do so for the
future Generations but we succeed only
if each and every member of this
organization stands firm in defending
its founding principles we proudly
recommitted to and the U.S 75
declaration I would like to underline
the importance of the peace formal
initiative and reiterate Georgia's
support to it this initiative goes
beyond the restoration of peace and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and has
more overarching aim of defending the
core values of the United Nations
distinguished delegates Georgia fully
aligns itself with the efforts of
international organizations as standard
solidarity with the people of Ukraine in
these trying times the government of
Georgia initiated and delivered
significant human right and support to
ukrainians on the ground as well as the
displaced persons from Ukraine residing
in Georgia excellencies
let me also use this opportunity to
voice Georgia's strong support to the
draft resolution before us today
which once again sends a clear signal
and defending all the core principles of
this Organization principles of
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and calls for a comprehensive just and
Lasting piece in the line with the U.N
Charter I would like to conclude by once
again reiterating our strong and
unwavering support to Ukraine's
territorial integrity and sovereignty
within its International internationally
recognized borders I thank you
I thank the minister for foreign affairs
of Georgia
and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Ian bork Minister for foreign
affairs and European Affairs and trade
of Malta
Secretary General president of the
general assembly excellencies
the general assembly this call today to
focus on the principles underlying a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
we remain Gravely concerned about the
ongoing war of aggression of the Russian
Federation against Ukraine
and reiterate that it is in violation of
the U.N Charter its values and the
rules-based international order
the International Community is
continuously horrified by the daily
reports including by the U.N independent
International Commission of inquiry on
Ukraine of attacks against civilians and
civilian infrastructure including homes
hospitals and schools
violence including sexual and
gender-based violence against women and
children and the use of torture
Russia's disregard for international law
must be condemned and denounced without
reservation
not withstanding The Bravery shown by
the Ukrainian people
the Russian Federation is further
pushing Ukraine into a grave
humanitarian crisis
40 percent of Ukraine's population is in
dire need of assistance nearly 8 million
people have fled to neighboring
countries
and 5.3 million are internally displaced
or unable to live illegally annexed
regions
the discovery
of mass graves in areas regained from
Russian occupation further underlines
the gravity of the situation
we reiterate that All Those who commit
Unleashed violations of international
humanitarian law and human rights law
must be held accountable
Malta will continue to support all
efforts by Ukraine and the International
Community to this end
the president
at every opportunity we have emphasized
the implications of this aggression on
the region the continent and globally
we have put the spotlight on the
humanitarian catastrophe that the
Ukrainian people are forced to endure
and the sufferings that the war has
brought to people around the world
we must continue to call on the Russian
Federation to withdraw all its forces
from the territory of Ukraine without
further delay
and to seek peaceful resolution of all
issues in accordance with international
law and the principles of the charter
Mr President
Malta reiterates that halting this war
of aggression against Ukraine at once is
the only way forward
there's no other way
ensuring accountability for perpetrators
of atrocity crimes committed and justice
for victims including victims of sexual
violence and the forced deportation of
children from Ukraine are a priority
we also reiterate our support to the
resolution 11-5 on the veterans of
Remedy and reparation for aggression
against Ukraine
Mr President
a fundamental principle in Article 2 of
the U.N Charter is the rejection of an
International System where might is
right
all United Nations member states today
must stop
think and Ponder on the gravity of the
current situation and what might be the
result if they don't speak out and
reaffirm by their vote the importance of
safeguarding a rules-based international
order
and the principles of the charter
it is our individual and Collective
responsibility and this particular time
to fight for these principles with all
our might and support of the UN Charter
and Malta therefore
urges all member states to support the
draft resolution being presented before
the general assembly let's vote Yes for
peace thank you
I thank the minister for foreign and
European Affairs and trade of Malta and
I'll give the floor to his Excellency
Peter lownski tiefenthal Deputy Minister
for foreign affairs of Austria
Mr President Excellence is distinguished
delegates
We Gather here today to Mark a somber
anniversary
almost one year has passed since Russia
launched an unprovoked
and unjustifiable wove aggression
against its neighbor Ukraine
one year of human suffering
one year of missiles and drones raining
down
on Ukrainian civilians
I witnessed the destruction and horrors
of this war myself upon my visit to
Ukraine late last year
everyone who has visited Ukraine in the
last 12 months
cannot return without having been deeply
touched
on a human level
and so have I
visiting Kiev and European looking into
the faces of small children
and their teachers
being grateful for a simple generator
so that the local kindergarten can be
heated
or meeting citizens standing in front of
their destroyed houses
being grateful for basic equipment such
as power Banks
so that they can stay in touch
with their loved ones
their faces are a reflection of the
cruelty senseless and human tragedy of
this war
we are impressed by the tremendous
courage and perseverance
ukrainians are demonstrating to us
their destiny is Our obligation
we said it one year ago and we repeat it
today
an attack against one member of this
organization
is an attack on all of us
that is what the U.N Charter in our
system
of collective security implies
Austria relies on the respect and
implementation of international law
treaties and Customs for its security
that is exactly why we cannot stand on
the sidelines
while the basic principles of our legal
and security order are under threat
we are never politically neutral and we
will never remain silent
when the sovereignty
territorial integrity and Independence
of a state is attacked
in the past year we've seen an
overwhelming support at the general
assembly to call on Russia to stop this
war
to stop the suffering of Ukraine's
population
to stop the nuclear threats
and to stop the blatant breaches of the
U.N Charter including the illegal
attempt to Annex whole regions of
Ukraine
we are encouraged by this overwhelming
show of solidarity with Ukraine in the
face of a brutal armed attack
and by the overwhelming support for
international law and for the U.N
Charter
we also expressed grave concerns about
the global consequences of this war
about the impact on food security the
rise in Energy prices the mass
displacement of persons
it is crucial to alleviate the global
consequences of this world
we commend the Secretary General for his
leadership
and the efforts of the government of
Turkey
in facilitating the Black Sea grain
initiative
as well as the grain from Ukraine
Austria fully supports its continued
renewal as well as its full unhindered
implementation
and we've listened to concerns and
understand that we must not lose sight
of other crisis which is why Austria is
continuing its strong and persistent
financial support
to humanitarian efforts around the world
Austria stands in full solidarity with
Ukraine the Ukrainian government and the
Ukrainian people
Austria has bilaterally provided 124
million euros in humanitarian assistance
with focus on winterization
support and basic needs and so much more
has already been done
in the past year we've seen millions of
lives uprooted in millions of people
fleeing their home to seek shelter
we would like to express our sincere
gratitude for the outstanding support of
the International Community for the
Ukrainian people and for the support of
Civil Society not only in Austria but in
all of its neighboring countries
we must also be clear that there is no
peace without Justice and without
accountability
Ukrainian cities such as Butcher and
Maria pool have become synonymous for
unspeakable human suffering
atrocities committed against the
civilian population
rape torture extrajudicial killings all
of these crimes must be investigated and
perpetrators held to account
we fully support all efforts to do so
including by the international criminal
court and the U.N Commission of inquiry
based in Vienna
one aspect that Austria contends in
condemns in the strongest possible terms
are the repeated implicit but
unmistakable threats made by Russia on
the use of nuclear weapons nuclear risks
are higher than they have been in
decades and they are potentially
devastating and Global humanitarian and
environmental consequences are a direct
security threat to the entire
International Community
we welcome efforts by the International
Community to work together foremost
through the iaea to secure the nuclear
energy facilities that have become
Targets in this world
we welcome proposals by its director
General Rafael Grossi to this effect and
are grateful for the tireless work of
the iaea teams present on the ground in
all nuclear power plants in Ukraine
all this underscores the utmost urgency
of progress on nuclear disarmament and
of moving away from the nuclear
deterrence Paradigm which is fraud with
immense risks and uncertainties at the
expense of the common security of all
Humanity
the International Community must come
together to ensure that the taboo
against any use of nuclear weapons is
not broken and that any threat or use
remains inadmissible
Excellence is distinguished delegates
Ukraine like every independent state and
member of the United Nations is entitled
to the stability and security of the
comprehensive just and Lasting peace a
peace based on international law and on
the U.N Charter
we call on Russia once again to stop
this war withdraw its troops from the
whole territory of Ukraine and end the
bloodshed
United Nations and other multilateral
organizations such as the organization
for security and cooperation in Europe
in Vienna are indispensable fora for
dialogue and peace in which member
states
which can resolve disputes through
dialogue is possible we must strengthen
and preserve these organizations and
enable them to fulfill their role the
resolution that will be adopted tomorrow
in this GA Hall
aims at an end to aggression Against The
Sovereign Nation an end to the global
consequences of this war a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace based on the
principles of the UN Charter
Austria therefore strongly supports this
text and we encourage all of you to vote
Yes on the general assembly resolutions
thank you
I thank the deputy Minister for foreign
affairs of Austria and I'll give the
floor to his Excellence Jerusalem
Secretary of State Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and European integration of the
Republic of Moldova
Mr President distinguished
Representatives
it's a deeply regrettable that the large
scale and the illegal invasion of the
Russian Federation against Ukraine has
already been going on for a year
in view of this it is more than critical
that we strongly support the resumption
of the special emergency session of the
UN General Assembly to discuss and make
decision with the principles underlying
the achievement of comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
distinguished delegates 12th month of
unprovoked and unjust war of aggression
have killed thousands of innocent people
and pushed millions of ukrainians to
flee their homes
12th month of the Brighton violation of
the event chapter and the principles of
the international law by one of the
permanent member members of the U.N
security Council whose primary
responsibility is to maintain peace
security worldwide
Russia's illegal and unprovoked attack
continuities a direct threats to the
sovereignty and Independence of Ukraine
has destabilized European security and
undermine global stability
we express our utmost admiration to all
ukrainians for their courage resilience
and inner power to pursue this fight for
survival Justice
and Freedom the Republic of Moldova
expressed its compassion with the
families of the victims and stands in
solidarity with the people of Ukraine in
this tough times
the Republic of Moldova has firmly
demonstrated its commitment and
engagement in the insurance protection
for those seeking the refugee in our
country we continue to offer support and
shelter the Ukrainian people who fled
the war
approximately 700
000 Ukrainian refugees have entered the
territory of the Republic of Moldova
since the beginning of the war in
Ukraine and other 80
000 remain to date in the country almost
half of them being children all of them
need a special protection
in this way the government of the
Republic of Moldova recently adopted
their decision to introduce from 1st of
March the temporary protection mechanism
for the Ukrainian refugees thus
contributing to a more efficient
management of the migration flows
legalization and access to fundamental
rights
we will also continue to provide
humanitarian support to Ukraine and
facilitate trending of goods through the
solidarity Lanes which are key to
ensuring food security and the global
level
Moldova has also felt this security
consequences of the war in Ukraine at
least four missiles targeting Ukraine
across our airspace and several
incidents of missiles debris landing on
our territory have happened
my country is also exposed to hybrid
threats and various means of pressure
we are committed to further countering
this risk in a systemic legal and
peaceful manner
Mr President
it is our moral duty as an International
Community to continue supporting Ukraine
Ukraine is faced is fighting today to
keep all of us safe to keep Europe safe
this world should not continue endlessly
we stress the need to ensure the
accountability for the atrocities
killing of civilians and damaging the
public infrastructure through timely
fair and independent investigations both
at the national and international level
this is of tremendous importance not
only for ensuring justice for all
victims of this war but also for
preventing future crimes
Mr President
Ukraine and the entire International
Community needs a way out of this war
which triggered multiple crises we
believe that the peaceful map proposed
by President zielinski is a
comprehensive package and has all
necessary ingredients to achieve a
lasting peace and prevent Another War
we also consider that the United Nations
needs to play a role in reaching and
securing peace in this regard the
Republic of Moldova has co-sponsored the
draft of resolution Yuan charity
principles underlying comprehensive just
and Lasting peace in Ukraine
which we hope will gang the support of
this August assembly
in conclusion we reiterate our call for
Russian Federation to the immediately
stop its war of aggression against
Ukraine withdraw all its forces and
military equipment from the Ukrainian
territory and respect ukrainians
sovereignty Independence and territory
Integrity within its International
recognized borders thank you
I thank the secretary of state of the
Republic of Moldova
and I'll get the floor to his Excellency
Bernardo Evo Cruz Vice Minister for
foreign affairs of Portugal
thank you Mr President
we align our statement with the one
delivered by the European Union and
would like to add the following points
in our national capacity this week we
mark one year since the Russian
leadership decided to invade Ukraine and
wage war against a sovereign country a
decision taken and implemented let us
not forget while the security Council
was in session discussing ways to
prevent it
since then we are counting 365 days of
unprovoked and unjustifiable aggression
which grossly violates the international
law and in particular the charter of the
United Nations we condemned Russia in
the strongest terms for this war and for
in the irresponsible nuclear rhetoric
the loss of life and human suffering
caused by this war cannot let us
indifferent the humanitarian situation
is dramatic have integered the worst
Refugee crisis in Europe since World War
II
figures are staggering thousands have
died and millions left the country or
became internally displaced the strategy
of relentlessly attack Critical
infrastructures with the tremendous
impact on civilian populations is
particularly repressive
Portugal supports the sovereignty
Independence unity and territorial
territory Integrity of the Ukraine we
will continue to provide assistance to
its government and people both
bilaterally and in the framework of the
European Union and of the United Nations
as long as it takes
Portugal is fast approaching the 600 the
6 000 requests for temporary protection
on our humanitarian Aid continues to
grow we are also engaged in the
Reconstruction of schools namely in
disappeared region
Mr President Beyond Ukraine the
consequences of the war are felt more
severely by the most vulnerable
population
suffering from a combination of impacts
of food Fuel and financial crisis this
emergency special session presents an
occasion to highlight the importance
role of the United Nations that has been
played in mitigation the global
consequences of the war
600 million people worldwide live in
food insecurity a figure that tends to
get worse
the Black Sea grain initiative has so
far allowed the shipment of more than 21
million tons of brain reaching regions
where it's most needed
remarkable achievement by the U.N also
due to the personal commitment of
Secretary General gutes
we also take part we all hope that all
parties will acknowledge the crucial
importance of this initiative ensuring
its continuity
many agencies funds and programs in the
U.N system are doing everything within
their capacity to address the global
consequences of the war let me just
mention a few of them the International
Organization for migrants dealing with
an unparalleled Refugee crisis in a
remarkable way
the international atomic energy agency
because this war has sadly revived the
dreads of a nuclear disaster
UNICEF which has sought to minimize the
impact of war in 0.75
0.7.5 million Ukrainian children
the Human Rights Council who
establishing of an independent
International Commission of inquiry on
the Ukraine is of Paramount importance
the world food program and the office of
the coordination of humanitarian Affairs
are among many of those working that
have made a really different so far
Mr President since the beginning of the
war this General Assembly has approved
several resolutions with the support of
a significant majority of its members
we must remain unite convening our
condemnation of this war convening that
the achievements of comprehensive just
and Lasting peace would indeed
constitute a significant and necessary I
would add contribution to the strengths
of International Peace and security as
mentioned in the draft resolution before
us
We Gather here today to protect the
multilateral system
and to uphold our respect for
international law for human rights and
the peaceful resolution of disputes
between states
furthermore Portugal is fully committed
to ensure accountability and will
continue to support initiatives aiming
at preventing violations fighting
impunity and
providing reparations for the Ukraine
Portugal supports all meanful efforts to
bring an end to this war of aggression
the path for peace is for the Russian
Federation to act in accordance to the
U.N Charter and respect the sovereignty
of the Ukraine redrawing from its
entirely territory we believe that the
draft resolution before us is an
important step in that direction and we
encourage all member states to support
it thank you very much
I thank the vice Minister for foreign
affairs of Portugal
and I'll give the floor to his
Excellency Martin a Olson permanent
Secretary of State Ministry of Foreign
Affairs of Iceland
Mr President
Iceland aligns itself with a statement
to be made tomorrow by Denmark on the on
behalf of the naughty countries
this is a sad moment
the general assembly of the United
Nations convenes in an emergency session
to mark that a year has passed since
Russia launched its unprovoked and
unjustifiable full-scale innovation of
Ukraine
Russia
a permanent member of the security
Council has with this horrendous Act of
aggression assaulted not only Ukraine
but our common institutions our common
values
and our basic human rights
rights and shrines in the very United
Nations chartered and the universal
Declaration of Human Rights
rights we have all subscribed to
rights that Russia has all also
subscribed to
our
admiration for the courage and the
resilience of the people of Ukraine
grows with each day
they valiantly defend their country
their sacrifice and suffering
must not be in vain
the foreign minister of Estonia
sat here a while ago
that the Ukrainian people were the
bravest people
on the world that I cannot only
subscribe to this
I can add to it as their Captain the
captain of Team Ukraine president
zelensky who's a bravest leader of the
world
and has
changed the whole meaning of the world
leadership
Mr President
the solution to end the war
is straightforward Russia can and must
stop this war today and withdraw all its
forces from Ukraine in full respect of
Ukraine's recognized right to
Independence sovereignty territorial
integrity and self-defense
let us also be reminded that ending the
war
is only the first step
to establish
just and Lasting peace for Ukraine is
also of critical importance
Russia must and will be held to account
for its actions
accountability for international crimes
committed within the context of the
world including the crime of aggression
is vital
it's vital to ensure Justice and
reparations
there can't be no impunity
accountability is indeed the only way to
ensure a lasting peace
Mr President
the Warfare contacted by Russia against
a member state is an act of aggression
that affects all of us
humanitarian concerns food security
Economic Development all these important
issues that weigh so much on our agenda
are hit by this senseless War
to sit idle on the fence or even support
the aggressor is beyond comprehension
it is our Collective responsibility to
end this war defend Ukraine and stand up
for the values and principle principles
that underpin the U.N Charter and the
work of this organization
that we the peoples owe to the people of
Ukraine and all other innocent victims
presently facing the courts of armed
conflict all over the world
that we owe to the previous generations
that built the system of international
law and the rule-based order from the
ruins of two world wars and their
Unforgettable Horrors
and that we owe to our children the
generations that we follow
Mr President Iceland remains unwavering
in its support and solidarity with
Ukraine we are committed to play our
part including in our role as the chair
of the Council of Europe
and we are a proud co-sponsor of the
Resolute draft resolution on just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine
I call on all member states to support
the draft resolution and vote against
the Belarus amendment of course I thank
you Mr President
I thank the distinguished permanent
Secretary of State of Iceland
and now I give the floor to Hurricane
Georgina guian foreign policy director
of the Minister of Foreign Affairs of
Costa Rica
Mr President Costa Rica Costa Rica is
attending this new emergency session of
the general assembly
has been unjustified
[Music]
as Humanity we all face
mental
numerous foreign
foreign
[Music]
weapon systems ever more powerful and
advanced as well as the military use of
artificial intelligence and the
development of autonomous weapons and
systems technologies
Justice
[Music]
foreign
now it's time to deliver
peace
Corporation and International
solidarities
to peace thank you very much
I thank the distinguished foreign policy
director of Costa Rica and now I give
the flow to the distinguished
representative of Oman speaking on
behalf of the gulf cooperation Council
his mercy and blessings of God be upon
you Mr President
ladies and gentlemen
I have the honor to deliver the
statement on behalf of the member states
of the gulf cooperation Council
the United Arab Emirates the Kingdom of
Bahrain the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia the
state of Qatar the state of Kuwait and
my own country the sultanate of Oman
Mr President
ladies and gentlemen
the GCC countries are following with
great interest
the developments of the situation in
Ukraine
in light of the increase and the number
of refugees and displaced people
the laws of Civilian lives
particularly women and children
in addition to the other damage
inflicted on infrastructure
which govern relations amongst
of the sovereignty
territorial Integrity of states
non-interference in their internal
affairs
for good neighborliness
in this context
we refer to Article 2 of the UN Charter
[Music]
According to which
all member states shall settle an
international disputes by peaceful means
or threatening to use Force an
international relationship
town
the GCC countries
the solution to disputes and
disagreements
lies in resorting to dialogue and
negotiations
and resolving disputes and differences
through peaceful and diplomatic means
ladies and gentlemen
the GCC member states have cordial
relations with all parties
we therefore encourage International and
Regional efforts to resolve this issue
in accordance with the internet
and based on the principles of the
European United Nations and it's shorter
zones
town
foreign
with regards to the protection of
civilians by refraining from targeting
or destroying any civilian facility
we also remind those parties of their
obligations under the international
humanitarian law
with regards to the wounded
prisoners and missing persons facilitate
the rapid and safe access to
humanitarian assistance for all those in
need and respect
the medical and humanitarian workers
workers
in conclusion
on behalf of the member states of the
GCC
the Relentless efforts made by the
United Nations and humanitarian
organizations
to promptly respond to the Urgent
humanitarian needs of civilians
we also we also thank the Secretary
General of the United Nations and all
authorities involved for their
significant and valuable efforts to
ensure the success of the Black Sea
grain initiative
Lil Azar which helped in restoring
stability into prices and food security
for many countries mainly developing
countries which are in dire need of
these grains and crops
we hope that this initiative will be
renewed in next march in conclusion
allow me to thank you for your attention
thank you Mr President I think
the ambassador of the sultanate of Oman
for his statement now I give the flow to
the distinguished representative of Fiji
speaking on behalf of the Pacific
Islands forum
foreign
excellencies
I have the honor to deliver these
remarks on behalf of members of the
Pacific Islands Forum with Presence at
the United Nations
I take this opportunity as well to offer
our deepest condolences to our Forum
Family
of our Forum Family to the peoples of
tikiya and Syria following the
devastating earthquakes
on the 6th of February and again only
this week
We Salute The Bravery of rescue teams
local and international who have battled
to save precious lives despite
significant aftershocks and dangerous
danger to themselves
such examples of our common Humanity are
relevant to the discussion which brings
us here today on this sad anniversary of
the illegal invasion of Ukraine by the
Russian Federation
excellencies like the climate emergency
which threatens our Blue Pacific
continent in this blue planet the
earthquakes in turkey and Syria reminds
us of the many Global challenges we need
to face together as one United Nations
family
we cannot afford to remain lost in an
Endless Sea of conflict
of Might is right and of unilateral
Force which tramples our shared values
so eloquently defined in our United
Nations Charter which we have all
solemnly accepted as our guiding and
foundational document
despite our distant geography our
Pacific family does not take this
position from the comfortable seat of my
spectator
our peoples know well the scourge of War
a micronesian melanesian and Polynesian
sub-regions have all seen sacrifice in
Volvos and Regional conflicts as
peacekeepers and Defenders of principles
of sovereignty and human dignity
despite our remoteness we also feel the
impacts of major disruptions to Global
Food and energy systems caused by this
war
effects of Russian federation's illegal
invasion of Ukraine's travels further
than bullets can fly far beyond
Ukraine's internationally recognized
borders these acts reach into our homes
making food and fuel unaffordable to our
citizens increasing the suffering of
people and economies already weakened by
covid-19 pandemic and especially those
at the margins of society
speak today on behalf of those further
marginalized by this illegal Invasion
those in our countries those in Ukraine
and around the world those trapped in
poverty the disabled children elderly
unable to flee the conflict or its
effects the U.N Charter demands this
offers in doing so we do not forget
those suffering in other conflicts in
this world neither do we reject this
Invasion to support the preeminence of
one geopolitical block over another we
remember the tragic results such
thinking caused in the 20th century
stained Forever by the two World Wars
the U.N Charter reminds us of this
instead we recognize that this illegal
Invasion threatens our hard one fragile
framework for peace and security of
Human Rights the rule of law and
development which underpin this
organization the U.N Charter
encapsulates this
we take heart that we are not alone and
welcome efforts by the Secretary General
and all good faith efforts by fellow
member states to promote comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
excellencies we do not claim that the
current world order has been perfected
know that Justice flows as freely as we
all desire however we do claim that the
rules-based international order offers
the best part towards a better world the
best instruments to seek Justice and
security and the best hope for our
common future we will support this
resolution we will ask you to join us
thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Fiji now
now I give the flower
to his Excellency
Deputy Minister of Foreign Affairs of
Sweden
Mr President
I delivered a statement in my national
capacity
Sweden Alliance itself with the
statements to be delivered by Denmark on
behalf of the Nordic countries and the
statement of the European Union
Mr President excellencies
there are moments in history which have
a before and then after
the 24th of February 2022 is one of them
today we mark one year of Russia's
brutal full-scale invasion of Ukraine
today we pay respect to those suffering
the consequences of the war and those
bravely fighting for their and our
freedom
and today and every day in this room and
around the world We Stand United for
Ukraine
the Russian aggression is not only a war
against Ukraine
it challenges the European and Global
Security order
it's a flagrant violation of one of the
most basic rules of international law
and the U.N Charter
and it is committed by a permanent
member of the security Council
this General Assembly has in the
strongest terms deplored the Russian
aggression and repeatedly demanded the
immediate complete and unconditional
withdrawal of Russian military forces
from the territory of Ukraine within its
International recognized borders and
reaffirmed the sovereignty Independence
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine it
has defended the U.N Charter
today we must again reiterate the loud
and clear message to uphold these rules
principles and values including by
adopting the draft resolution tabled it
is in all our interests
during the first half of 2023 Sweden
holds the EU presidency
and no other task is more important to
us than strong and continued support for
Ukraine and mounting pressure on Russia
since Russia's full-scale Invasion
Sweden support Ukraine has increased
with 1.2 billion Euro in financial
humanitarian and Military Support
the EU has contributed with 50 billion
Euro
we will support Ukraine and the
Ukrainian people against Russia's
ongoing war of aggression for as long as
it takes
accountability for the crimes committed
as part of Russia's aggression against
Ukraine must be insured and it will be
we continue to condemn Russians
violations of international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
the summary executions
the torture the sexual and gender-based
violence and the forced deportations are
only a few examples of Russia's
unacceptable violations of international
law
all crimes must be investigated and
those responsible must be brought to
Justice
this is crucial for redress and Justice
both for Ukraine as a country and for
the victims and survivors
President Putin Bears the primary
responsibility for Russia's violations
of international law Russian decision
makers also bear individual criminal
responsibility for the aggression
against Ukraine
impunity is not an option for Russia's
blatant violation of the U.N Charter
Ukraine and its people are paying the
highest price for the Russian invasion
but the consequences are striking far
beyond Ukraine and far beyond Europe
Russia's aggression affects the most
vulnerable the hardest adding to already
severe hardships brought about by
climate change and the pandemic
Sweden and the rest of the EU is working
together to mitigate these Global
effects of the Russian aggression on
food security energy Finance the
environment and nuclear Safety and
Security
We Stand ready to listen to engage and
to continue providing support as we have
done consistently and significantly
we remain committed Partners including
to making progress on the sdgs and
addressing climate change
so today We Gather in this assembly to
express our solid International
commitment to achieve a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine based
on the principles of the U.N Charter
Russia must immediately and completely
cease military operations
unconditionally withdraw all forces and
military equipment from the entire
territory of Ukraine and fully respect
Ukraine's territorial Integrity
sovereignty and Independence within its
internationally recognized borders
Russia can end this war Russia must end
this war and it must do it now thank you
for your attention
I thank the distinguished Deputy
minister of Sweden
and now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of the
bolivarian Republic of Venezuela
foreign
[Music]
13 countries
foreign
an opportunity to peace
very survival of current and future
Generations
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Mr President
it is tragic that the general assembly
has to convene
yet another meeting of the emergency
special session
because this means that the war in
Ukraine is continuing
with full force causing the loss of so
many innocent lives
and massive destruction to civilian
infrastructure
Russia amid the Fateful decision
to invade Ukraine
in blatant disregard of the U.N Charter
a year ago
since then we have witnessed a war of
attrition
with spillover effects that have touched
all parts of the world
and it appears that the situation may
worsen further
since the beginning of this war
Singapore has taken a clear
and consistent position
that Russia's unjustifiable invasion of
Ukraine is a clear and gross violation
of the principles of the U.N Charter
and of international law
the U.N security Council
of which Russia is a permanent member
has regrettably
not been able to discharge its primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security
because of the self-serving
cynical veto by Russia
the general assembly has so far adopted
five resolutions
on the war in Ukraine
each of these resolutions
is a clear message from the
International Community
that the violation of the sovereignty
and territorial integrity
of Ukraine cannot be condoned
we regret
that Russia has ignored the clear and
repeated calls of the general assembly
to immediately
completely
and unconditionally withdraw all of its
military forces
from the territory of Ukraine
and to respect Ukraine's internationally
recognized borders
Russia has also ignored the orders of
the international court of justice
to immediately suspend
the special military operation
in inverted commas the special military
operations
which commenced
on the 24th of February 2022 in the
territory of Ukraine
we underline also
the importance of general assembly
resolution
ES
11-4
which condemned
the Russian federation's organization
of illegal so-called referenda in
Ukraine's internationally recognized
borders in October 2022
Mr President we thank the Secretary
General for his remarks earlier today
and we fully agree with the Secretary
General
when he said and I quote
Russia's attack on Ukraine
challenges the Cornerstone principles
and values of our multilateral system
end of quote
in addition to these remarks from the
Secretary General
please allow me to make some additional
points
on the important issue that we are
discussing this afternoon
firstly
Singapore is clear and consistent
position
on brushes invasion of Ukraine remains
unchanged
we are upholding a fundamental principle
we are not taking sides
our clear and consistent position
reflects our firm belief in the need to
respect the sovereignty
Independence and territorial Integrity
of all states
big or small
we reaffirm article 2.4 of the U.N
Charter which states unequally vocally
and I quote
that all members shall refrain in their
international relations from the threat
or use a force
against the territorial Integrity or
political Independence
of any state
and a court
and let me add that for small states
like Singapore
the U.N Charter and international law
are not academic issues
but a matter of peace and security
and of existential importance
we therefore condemn and the strongest
possible terms
any violation of these principles
which are
of fundamental importance to all member
states of the United Nations
Singapore
has co-sponsored
the draft resolution before us today
because we believe
that the resolution expresses support
for a comprehensive just and Lasting
peace in Ukraine
based on the principles of the UN
Charter
and we hope
that such a peace will come to pass
secondly Singapore is saddened by the
continued deterioration of the
humanitarian situation in Ukraine
with continuing indiscriminate attacks
on civilians
and civilian infrastructure
Rising casualties
and a lack of humanitarian access to
those most in need
we share the grave concern
expressed in this draft resolution
on the high number of Civilian
casualties
including women and children
we support the call made in the
resolution for an immediate secession of
attacks on the critical infrastructure
of Ukraine
and any deliberate attacks on civilian
objects including those that are
residences
schools and hospitals
we commend the work of various U.N
agencies
and the international Committee of the
Red Cross
providing humanitarian Aid to elevate
the suffering of the Ukrainian people
and others affected by the war and its
spillover effects
we also thank the iaea
for its work to ensure nuclear Safety
and Security in Ukraine in spite of the
challenging situation
on the ground
thirdly
Singapore shares the concerns expressed
in the resolution
but the effects of the war on global
food and energy Supply chains and prices
the spillover effects have dampened the
economic recovery and growth
and has set back the progress made in
the global fight against poverty
in this regard we commend the secretary
General's tireless efforts
to ensure continued Supply
of essential exports through the Black
Sea grain initiative
we call upon the Secretary General to
continue his good office's role by
facilitating contact and dialogue
with all relevant parties in order to
support a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine
Mr President the resolution before us
today
is a balanced one
that reiterates the principles of the
U.N Charter
and international law
the resolution emphasizes the need to
redouble support
for diplomatic efforts to reach a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine in accordance
with the principles of the U.N Charter
we welcome the call made in the
resolution for a secession of
hostilities and for the immediate
complete and unconditional withdrawal by
the Russian Federation of it of all of
its military forces
from the territory of Ukraine
Singapore
urges all member states
to vote Yes for this draft resolution
in order to demonstrate support for
international law
for the U.N Charter
and for the rules-based multilateral
system
the adoption of this draft resolution
before us today
will send a clear signal to the world
that the sovereignty and territorial
integrity
of all states must be respected
that internationally recognized borders
cannot be violated by the rule of force
and that a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace in Ukraine must be based
on the principles of the U.N Charter I
thank you for your attention
I thank the distinguished representative
of Singapore
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Liechtenstein
thank you Mr President
to president
a year ago Russia decided to escalate
its aggression against Ukraine in a
manner that is both terrifying and
Carries very wide implications beyond
the region this past year has seen
horrific crimes that are difficult to
process in their scale
and systematic nature
in the course of digression
Russian forces have systematically
violated all fundamental principles of
international humanitarian law
military necessity distinction and
proportionality
civilians
including children have been forcibly
abducted into Russia
unable to score the expected military
gains Russia has resorted to a tactic
of terrorizing the resilient civilian
population into submission including
through a pattern of attacks
on critical civilian infrastructure
furthermore its leadership
has sent hundreds of thousands of his
own young men
many conscripted to a senseless and
unnecessary death
Mr President the impacts of the
aggression
are being felt far and wide
food security for tens of Millions
while somewhat ameliorated by the
progress of the Black Sea grain
initiative
feel free to be set back as Ukraine's
natural environment is polluted with the
detritus of War
the Doomsday Clock is now set at 90
seconds to midnight
the closest it has ever been after
threats by the Russian leadership of a
nuclear apocalypse
collectively
this aggression has seriously undermined
Global progress towards the 2030
agenda
and made a major contribution to the
world in which displacement and hunger
sit at record levels
let us be clear about why
we have this war Ukraine did not want it
NATO did not want it no peace-loving
State wanted it
the political and Military leadership of
the Russian Federation alone
wanted it and chose to invade a
sovereign neighboring state
they did so in blatant violation of the
founding principles of the U.N Charter
and the fundamental tenets of
international law with complete
disregard for human life
and for the devastating resulting
Fallout for people around the globe
the UN is a peace organization created
From the Ashes of war in order to save
future Generations from experiencing
it's Horrors
its Charter has thus outlawed the use of
force with two exceptions
authorization by the security Council
and self-defense
this aggression is therefore manifestly
illegal
Ukraine's efforts to defend itself
on the other hand are not only legal
under article 51 of the charter they are
fully in line with its object and
purpose
Mr President we have co-sponsored the
draft resolution that this assembly will
take action on tomorrow
adjust peace must be grounded in the
principles of the UN Charter
in particular that of territorial
integrity
as disassembly demanded in March
2022 Russia must immediately and
completely withdraw all of its troops
from all of Ukraine only then will it be
possible to engage in China in genuine
diplomacy
and will there be space for credible and
full inclusive peace talks
we call on all states
to support this draft which epitomizes
the values of this organization
Mr President the resolution also
highlights the role of accountability as
a key element in a just and Lasting
piece
this includes in particular
accountability for the crime of
aggression
from which all the other International
crimes committed in the course of this
war flow
disassembly has recognized individual
criminal responsibility for the crime
against peace the precursor of the crime
of aggression as customary international
law as early as in 1946
in 1974 it defined by consensus
but acts of aggression are
and it has twice determined with an
overwhelming majority
in the past year that the Russian
Federation has committed aggression
against Ukraine
ensuring individual criminal
accountability for persons in political
and Military leadership positions in
line with the international law is
therefore an obvious task for this
assembly
both in line with you and Charter and
with its own Landmark decisions from the
past
we therefore appeal to all states to
join the effort to create a special
Tribunal for the crime of aggression and
in doing so to live up to our commitment
to save succeeding Generations from the
spiritual war I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
Liechtenstein
now I give the flow to the distinction
Center table of Luxembourg
Mr President
Mr President in Luxembourg fully aligns
itself with the statement Union
some thoughts in my national capacity
we thank you Mr President for having
followed up on our request to reopen the
11th emergency special session of the
general assembly
as long as the world
devoted to the principles of the charter
of the United Nations
and Lasting peace in Ukraine lyrics
and we'll vote in favor of this draft
resolution
which is the result of inclusive and
transparent consultations
to vote in favor
indeed in all of our interests to defend
the charter and to underscore them as
quickly as possible to reach a
comprehensive just and Lasting peace in
accordance with the principles
in particular the principles of
sovereign
the Russian Federation not only attacked
Ukraine it also attacks
International order based on the rule of
law which is based on the fundamental
provisions of the United Nations Charter
it is our responsibility to respond to
this actress by reiterating the
principles of the chartered by helping
Ukraine to defend itself
defense enshrined in article 51 of the
charter
and those are the cases that have been
able to be verified the real number of
Civilian casualties is much higher
the continued use of explosive weapons
including in populated areas
thousands of schools preschools and
other educational facilities in Ukraine
have been damaged
more than 5 million children in Ukraine
Elizabeth
targeted attacks against schools and
hospitals and other civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine constant
violation of international humanitarian
law and international human rights law
the project resolution the draft
resolution is foreign
foreign
crimes against humanity and the crime of
genocide
is not able to exercise its
jurisdictions over the crime of
aggression in this case we are among the
internationally recognized
thank you
I thank the distinguished ambassador of
Luxembourg
and now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of the
United Kingdom
thank you Mr President
[Music]
one year ago
we met in this Hall
as one hundred and thirty thousand
Russian troops amassed on Ukraine's
borders
and in illegally annexed Crimea
many of us called for de-escalation
for dialogue
and for respect for the UN Charter
Russia
claimed it had no intention to invade
the next day
Russia launched its full-scale invasion
with Belarus providing one of the
staging grounds
we're all aware of the devastating
impacts
millions of civilians displaced
countless lives Ukrainian and Russian
lost
hundreds of hospitals and thousands of
schools destroyed
a generation of Ukrainian families
scarred by abuses trauma
and forced deportation
and across the world
increased food insecurity and energy
prices
affecting every country
and really hurting those most in need
in response
the general assembly has now met in this
emergency special session six times in
the past year
it has repeatedly called for Russia to
end its Invasion and withdraw from
Ukraine
it has condemned Russia's illegal
attempts to Annex Ukrainian territory
and it has reaffirmed our respect for
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and demanded respect for the UN Charter
yet Russia continues
more indiscriminate attacks on Ukrainian
cities and towns and endless systematic
strikes on Ukraine's water electricity
and other infrastructure
a war on the Ukrainian people and their
right to exist
Ukraine has resisted
day in and day out for every one of the
last 364 days
exercising Its Right of self-defense
under the charter
as foreign minister kuleba said earlier
every country in this assembly would
fight to survive in the same way
but beyond its survival
what Ukraine really wants
indeed what we all want
we have continually called for
is a just peace
tomorrow
we will vote on a resolution
it is a resolution that underlines the
need for a comprehensive just and
Lasting peace
a peace that guarantees Ukraine
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and ends Russia's constant aggression
a vote in favor of the resolution is a
vote for peace and for the UN Charter
we urge all of you to join us in voting
yes
[Music]
I thank the distinguished representative
Kingdom
now I give the floor to Miss Victoria
Hallam
deputy secretary Minister of Foreign
Affairs and trade of New Zealand
thank you Mr President
aotearoa in New Zealand reiterates our
unequivocal condemnation of the Russian
federation's blatant aggression against
Ukraine
one year into this illegal and
unprovoked conflict the repercussions
for Global Peace security and economic
stability continue to reverberate around
the world
terrible loss of life a humanitarian
crisis
economic upheaval
our resolve to stand against the Russian
federation's aggression is undiminished
Russia's actions are a direct attack on
the principles that underpin Global
Peace and security
the only way for Russia to rebuild its
credibility as an international citizen
is to end this war
we call again on the Russian Federation
to commit to dialogue
to act in the interests of peace and in
compliance of the United Nations Charter
and The Binding orders of the
international court of justice
Russia has a duty to act consistently
with its responsibilities as a permanent
member of the United Nations security
Council
aotearoa New Zealand strongly supports
Ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
our position is reflected in our
response
aotearoa New Zealand has acted swiftly
with unprecedented diplomatic economic
and Military Support for Ukraine's
self-defense
as members of the general assembly it is
our responsibility to do all we can to
avoid the deadly consequences of War
the principles at stake in Ukraine
namely respect for international law and
the U.N Charter's defense of sovereignty
and territorial Integrity are of
critical importance to aoteroa New
Zealand and for the peace and stability
of small states
the passage of time does not lessen our
opposition to the Russian federation's
Act of aggression against Ukraine
we call on all states to maintain
pressure on Russia to show that its
actions are not without consequence
aotearo and New Zealand is committed to
ensuring there is legal accountability
in Ukraine including through the
international court of justice and the
international criminal court
aotearoa New Zealand chooses peace
we do not support the cynical amendments
proposed by Belarus
we are pleased to co-sponsor today's
resolution and we urge other states to
add their support
We Stand shoulder to shoulder with
Ukraine
thank you Mr President
I thank the deputy foreign Secretary of
New Zealand
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Turkey
foreign
let me start by thanking your Excellency
for recombining the element emergency
special session or the general assembly
we have gathered at the somber moment
the very fact that the war in the
Ukraine enters its second year
with little prospective peace is
disheartening
yet it is a timely opportunity to take
stock and reaffirm
fundamental principles that guide our
policies
since day one
turkey
has adopted a principal position
in terms of rejecting the war in Ukraine
and calling it unacceptable
we also tried
to facilitate diplomacy at an early
stage
both in Antalya and in Istanbul
we have manifested our position by
co-sponsoring or voting in favor of all
relevant U.N General Assembly
resolutions
indeed
our position is a natural extension of
our opposition
to the illegal annexation of Crimea
one year wrong
took his position remains unchanged
we fully support Ukraine's territorial
integrity
Independence and sovereignty
we continue to stand firmly against this
war
and reject the annexation of the
Ukrainian territories
we must ensure that the founding
principles of the U.N enshrined in its
Charter are upheld
Mr President
the repercussions of the conflict
are being felt far beyond Ukraine
with profound Global implications
the material and human cost
is mounting
the war has had a negative impact on
searching Energy prices High Cost of
Living
supply chain problems and food
insecurity
this happens at a time
when the global governance is already
struggling with the challenges posed by
an interconnected
interdependent and digitalized world
therefore
the trajectory of the conflict cannot be
decided by the Dynamics of the
Battleground only
a Clear Vision for ending this war
through diplomacy has to be articulated
sooner rather than later
we must focus our efforts
on Crafting The Contours of a realistic
sustainable
and above all
viable peace
the Black Sea grain initiative has
proved that diplomacy can indeed deliver
results
as we enter the second tier of this
conflict
turkey will remain engaged
in all efforts towards this end I thank
you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Turkey
now I give the flow to the distinguished
entity of Chile
emergency special session of this
General Assembly
we the peoples of the United Nations
from the scourge of War
we're all aware those reads the
beginning of the United Nations
for 77 years
since then and today
as well as to the commitments with
international law
and human rights
laws
and to always maintain that the only
solution to this foreign
so
consequences
and have robust and credible legal
verification mechanisms
nuclear weapons
must be eradicated
Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Chile
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of the Republic of Korea
Mr President excellencies ladies and
gentlemen we are gathered here once
again today
for an emergency special session
as we solemnly commemorate one year
since Russia's illegal Invasion against
Ukraine and its people
for the past year the war in Ukraine has
created Untold human suffering and
countless tragedies
it is deeply troubling to see that there
is no there is so little hope in sight
for a peaceful resolution
how many more days must we bear witness
to civilian casualties and the
destruction of the Beloved homes of
Ordinary People
it is simply deplorable that we we have
to discuss at the podium of the U.N
General Assembly Hall a war of
aggression raised by a permanent member
of the security Council in the 21st
century
the impacts of this war are not
constrained within Ukraine's borders
rather the International Community is
continuing to Grapple with the
far-reaching repercussions of this war
in addition there is a fundamental
damage according to all of us
our common principles are so flagrantly
preached and the rules-based
international order is under attack
Russia's
armed invasion of Ukraine and its
annexation of Ukrainian territories
through the use of force a serious blows
to the core principles of the
International System that we have been
upholding over the last seven decades
these include our solemn obligation to
refrain from the use of force against
the territorial Integrity or political
independence of any state
in this regard the security Council has
failed to act according to its primary
responsibility for the maintenance of
International Peace and security as a
result of the veto cast by by Russia
we the security Council still deadlocked
on the situation in Ukraine the general
assembly must Advance a firm unified
voice on behalf of the fundamental
principles which bind us together
Mr President the uniting for peace
resolution which forms the basis of
today's emergency special session is all
the more meaningful to the Republic of
Korea since it was born in 1950 during
the Korean War due to the veto willed by
the Soviet Union
through the previous emergency special
sessions on the situation in Ukraine we
have adopted five resolutions which all
demonstrated our strong commitment to
the UN chapter
the Republic of Korea as a nation which
was founded defended and then rebuilt
alongside the crucial assistance of the
U.N and as a nation which is adamantly
committed to Universal values such as
Freedom human rights and the rule of law
proudly co-sponsored all of these
resolutions
and we once again co-sponsored the
resolution today
my delegation expects all member states
to vote in favor of the resolution today
which is principally about our common
values and guiding principles
this is not about taking size this is
about our joint commitment to upholding
the U.N Charter and the rules-based
international order
Mr President the Republic of Korea urges
Russia to immediately end
unconditionally withdraw its forces from
the territory of Ukraine and to end its
continuing violations of the U.N Charter
this war can be stopped by Russia's
choosing as was the invasion one year
ago was its choice
the extended wall will only strengthen
International solidarity against Russia
and will not serve Russia's interest
Russia should devise an actionable
access strategy for both World Peace as
well as its own interests
the sooner the better
in the meantime we support Ukraine's
exercise of its inherent right to
self-defense on the article 51 of the
U.N Charter we reiterate our full
solidarity with Ukraine and its people
my delegation urges all parties to the
conflict to abide by humanitarian and
human rights laws
we believe that violations of
humanitarian and human rights laws must
be held accountable furthermore my
delegation condemns all other illicit
activities on the ground such as the
arms trade between the dprk and the
Wagner group
in blatant violation of relevant
Security Council resolutions
as we're now moving into the second year
of the war we are compelled to ask
we are compared to raise a key question
whose side is time on
the answer is we firmly believe that
time is on the side of freedom justice
human rights the rule of law and the U.N
Charter not on the side of mass
atrocities
thank you Mr President
I thank the representative of the
distinguished
a republic of Korea I now give the floor
to the distinguished representative of
Ecuador
this is
General
in ukrania
apocas oras de complete absurda
okay
this session is now reviewing for the
sixth time
in the beginning of this emergency
provisions
sovereign
Arena which is
important deliberative representative
and Democratic Arena
Nations
and appeal for it to be defended since
then how many times
before an end to military aggression how
many times
of the United Nations
According to which states we must
refrain from the threat or use of force
against the territorial Integrity of
another state
peaceful resolution of disputes
contained
a comprehensive just and Lasting peace
the Amendments presented by Belarus seek
to divide
to undermine the aforementioned draft
resolution L7
borisa
is
killed during this first year
the invasion it was Elisa who was seven
Paulina is
only two months these people
because they were buried under the bombs
in the foreign
thank you very much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Ecuador I now give the flow to the
distinguished representative of the
martial
foreign
excellencies the Republic of the
Marshall Islands strongly reaffirms the
paliker communique of the 21st
micronesian president's Summit of 13
February 2023 in which the five leaders
of the micronesian island nations and I
quote condemned the illegal brutal and
unjustified invasion of Ukraine by the
Russian Federation which is nearly
approaching its one year anniversary
presidents agreed that the rule of law
the international rule-based order
and respect for sovereignty and human
rights must prevail
presidents call on the International
Community to help towards reinstalling
peace and stability in that region in
court
Mr President the words of small island
leaders in the vast expenses of the
North Pacific Ocean I have world away
are also those of democratic nations
committed to accountability and
fundamental human rights we are as
concerned over the Russian invasion as
we are also over the sharp tone of
geopolitical Confrontation in our own
region
and a small nation of vulnerable
populations we rely closely upon
effective multilateral outcomes
in its aggression again Ukraine Russia
and its actors have committed documented
atrocities against Ukraine with such
deliberate planning and at such skill it
is typical not to Define them as crimes
against humanity
Mr President the United the united
nation was founded out of a clear
commitment to never repeat atrocities
and an instability
the present Russian aggression against
Ukraine has put us all to the test
a difunctional security Council held by
the very safe self-interest and with
veto power under question will not
silent the general assembly
the U.N Charter is not neutral
it demands adherence to the universal
and fundamental human rights and it is
it is so to protect the most vulnerable
countries and peoples who are otherwise
threatened by larger powers it is
incumbent incumbent Upon Us member
states
turn these normal words into reality
today sport is an ambiguous and might
send a clear and common voice
the public credibility of this institute
each reason we all belong to rest upon
it
in the past year we have seen evidence
of appalling atrocities including
indiscriminate targeting Devastation
conflict related sexual violence and
landscale removal of Civilian from
Ukraine to Russia including attraction
of children
and accordingly accountability mechanism
are now at work while these deliberate
processes must take time no one can
ignore the overwhelming Clarity and
weight of documentation
Mr President the International Community
is at a unique moment the post called
World War
Cold War era is long over
and the boundaries of the new moments
are uncertain
increasingly we are defined by
correlations and stronger group effort
what issues once may have divided us
often to no longer
those committed to speaking out against
war crimes and human rights violation
are simply now stronger as a result of
this experience
and we are stronger together and we will
not be divided
and while some of may choose to still
vote only to the on the basis of
politics either do so to express moral
character
that's it Mr President we are prepared
to submit support until addressed and
Lasting peace is rich
today the Marshall Island Republic of
the Marshall Island we fall will vote
Yes on resolution L7 on a chest and
Lasting peace in Ukraine and urges
others to vote likewise I thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of the Marshall Islands I now give the
floor to the distinguished
representative of Israel
foreign
[Music]
for the past year Israel has stood
alongside the people of Ukraine in
solidarity both on the ground and here
in the United Nations
Israel will continue our solidarity with
Ukraine by supporting this resolution
and every other resolution that reflects
our position at the United Nations
the state of Israel has always and
continues to remain wholeheartedly
committed to Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity
ambassador kislitzia
you are a dear friend on a personal
level
but this friendship extends far beyond
us
it is shared between our Nations as well
distinguished Representatives
one of the most fundamental values in
Jewish tradition is the sanctity of life
according to our sages whoever saves
even one life
is as if they saved an entire world
this is a principle that Israel the
Jewish State holds dear
this is seen through Israel's support
and Aid around the world whenever
disaster strikes and whenever there are
those in need
but when Ukraine needed support Israel
immediately took action
within one week of the fighting over 100
tons of humanitarian equipment
Aid and Aid was delivered to our
Ukrainian friends
in coordination with the Ukrainian
authorities thousands of codes blankets
tents and sleeping bags were shipped
from then until today
medication
food water purification systems
industrial sized generators and so much
more has been delivered
just weeks ago Israel delivered armored
ambulances to Ukraine
Israel was proud to establish a field
Hospital inside Ukraine's borders
it was at this hospital that 7 000
patients were treated in the diarist of
times
staffed by roughly 200 doctors nurses
and health professionals the field
Hospital included words for men women
and children an emergency room labor and
delivery facilities
Imaging and Telehealth capabilities
Mental Health Services and Far Beyond
yet the field Hospital wasn't the only
Israeli hospital that ukrainians
received treatment in
hundreds of Ukrainian patients have been
treated in hospitals and rehabilitation
centers across Israel
from giving critical care to Children
suffering from cancer to wounded
soldiers receiving state-of-the-art
protestics
Israeli doctors and medical
professionals have been wholly committed
to helping ukrainians in need
of Israel's agency for International
cooperation has provided crucial crucial
training to thousands of Ukrainian
Professionals in the fields of Emergency
Management welfare and post-trauma
therapy
but now dear friends
one year on is not the time to allow our
support to ebb
and this is precisely the commitment
that Israel made last week with the
visit of our Minister of Foreign Affairs
to Ukraine
Israel remains steadfast in continuing
our support and even expanding it
by advancing projects in healthcare and
civilian infrastructure across Ukraine
as well as aiding in the development of
a smart early warning system to save
Ukrainian lives from imminent rocket and
missile attacks
distinguished colleagues
for years now Israel has been warning
the International Community of the most
dangerous threat to the Middle East
the Ayatollah regime in Iran
but now dear colleagues now the
International Community has begun to
wake up
the Ayatollah regime is not merely a
threat to the Iranian people murdering
protesters and women in the streets it
is not only a danger to the Middle East
with its public calls for Israel's
destruction
its attack on Maritime shipping routes
and Iran's funding and arming of
destabilizing terrorist armies
the ayatollahs are a worldwide threat
and for Ukraine this couldn't be clearer
Iranian arms and weaponry are wrecking
havoc in Ukraine killing innocent
civilians and destroying infrastructure
and this is just the beginning
[Music]
Ukraine has been a testing ground for
Iran and their armaments are now being
sold to some of the most dangerous
International actors
if this is what the Iranian threat look
looks like today I truly cannot imagine
what it will be like
should Iran become a nuclear threshold
state
think about it it is time for the
International Community to not just wake
up but to act against the Iranian threat
Act
for the sake of the Iranian people for
the Middle East for Ukraine and for the
sake of the world
Iran must be stopped
Mr President Israel stands strongly with
our Ukrainian friends
remains committed to the sovereignty and
territorial Integrity of Ukraine and is
fully devoted to saving lives in any way
possible Israel is proud to strengthen
its mission of humanitarian support and
looks forward to expanding cooperation
and advancing more projects to assist
Ukraine I pray I pray dear friends for
an end to the violence and for peace not
only in Europe but around the globe
thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Israel I now give
[Music]
foreign
to the distinguished representative of
Mexico
Senora
Presidente
a unano Del initio Del conflicto armado
in ukrania
Mexico
Los Estados
unidas
impulsar Siempre action is
[Music]
Constitution
ISTA
moment
s
criticus
Humanity
conferencia
is
Senor Presidente
Ramos International
de cuentas
Mexico
interior
El projecto de resolution
participated
respeto de la Carta de las naciones
universe
ukrania
sumanos
o Colectivo in favor
consideration
paraphernalizarre
Mexico
[Music]
is
Mexico reconos
ukrania
irrespalda
today
I thank the distinguished representative
of Mexico I now give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Australia
Mr President colleagues good evening
Australia is proud proud to stand
alongside our partners to co-sponsor
this resolution underscoring the need
for a comprehensive just and Lasting
piece in Ukraine
and let me be clear at the outset
one year on Australia continues to
condemn Russia's illegal and immoral
full-scale invasion of Ukraine
this aggression cannot be normalized
this aggression cannot be minimized
we strongly support the sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
Mr President we urge all member states
to support this resolution
doing so demonstrates our unreserved
commitment to upholding international
law
in particular the charter of the United
Nations
it confirms that we will not accept a
situation where larger countries
determine the fate of smaller countries
it shows President Putin that Russia's
prolonged War impacts all nations in all
peoples
it is not only causing immense human
suffering but also exacerbating existing
stresses in the global economy
constraining growth increasing inflation
disrupting Supply chains and heightening
energy and food insecurity
President Putin's destabilizing Behavior
the nuclear threats are acts of
hostility
threatening the peace and security of
all
Mr Putin's joint statement with the
leaders of the other four nuclear weapon
States in January last year emphasize
that and I quote
nuclear war cannot be won and must never
be fought end quote
this commitment should not be forgotten
Mr President
Australia calls on Russia to end its War
and to unconditionally withdraw from
Ukraine's territory
consistent with the legally binding
decision of the international court of
justice
the ongoing injuries suffered by Ukraine
as a result of Russia's violations of
international law also require full
reparation by Russia
Australia has imposed sanctions on
Belarusian and Iranian targets involved
in Russia's War efforts
we reiterate that those who provide
material support to Russia will face
consequences
the Australian government for its part
has committed approximately 655 million
dollars in assistance to empower Ukraine
to resolve this conflict on its own
terms
and make the immediate needs of
Ukrainian people
Australia continues to work with our
partners to hold Russia accountable
we have imposed over 900 targeted
Financial sanctions on those responsible
and comprehensive Import and Export Bans
the strata continues to work with
Partners to impose costs on Russia in
the multilateral system to show that The
Invasion has severe consequences for its
Global standing
Mr President
Australia again calls on Russia to
immediately comply with its obligations
under international law including the
charter of the United Nations and
international humanitarian law
it is imperative that we ensure
accountability for the commission of
serious International crimes in Ukraine
that's why we continue to support the
important work of the international
criminal court and independent U.N
Commission of inquiry
on 24 February Mr President
Australia will make further
announcements to mark one year since
Russia's full-scale invasion
we will continue to call for the
sovereignty of all Nations large and
small to be respected
Australia Mourns the incalculable losses
inflicted by The Invasion and honors the
resilience of the Ukrainian people
Mr President colleagues
Russia's attack on Ukraine is an attack
on all and reminds us how much we all
have to lose if we fail to protect the
UN system thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Australia
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of the
federal States of Micronesia
[Music]
Mr President I aligned the statement
with the statement delivered by a
distinguished representative of Fiji
on behalf of the Pacific island forum
in my national capacity I would like to
add a few points
it has been a year since the 11th
emergency
special session of the general assembly
adopted a resolution on the aggression
against Ukraine
since then the war has only intensified
with disturbing human rights violation
wage against the people of Ukraine by
Russia
the ongoing unjust War
has displaced millions of people with
insurmountable death and destruction
it is disconcerting to see Russia's
utter disregard
for the call from the International
Community
for a cessation of their hostilities
toward the people of Ukraine
and to withdraw all of its military
forces from the territory of Ukraine
within its internationally recognized
borders
we once again express our appreciation
to its neighbors who continue to provide
food
shelter and safety for the most
vulnerable
today's draft
tries to look towards the future
it underscores the need to reach a
comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine in
line with the principles of the charter
of the United Nations
it reaffirms the commitment
to the sovereignty
Independence
Unity
and territorial Integrity of Ukraine
within its internationally
recognized borders
extending to his territorial Waters
and it recalls the obligations under
International humanitarian law
Micronesia supports the draft and is one
of the sponsors thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Micronesia
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Liberia
[Music]
Mr President
excellences
a year ago
the world witnessed Russia's evasion of
Ukraine
for me
this led to immediate Recollections of
Liberia's dark days
marked by heartened insecurity
displacements in Turner and across
borders
hunger
disease
fears deaths and many forms of human
rights violations
these are just few of the trauma of war
with effects often last in a lifetime
Liberia
a country with first-hand experience of
War
understands this very well
the feeling of uncertainty
constant fear and loss
leaving your home and all you know in
search of safety and basic necessities
like food shelter and clothings waking
up and not knowing whether you will
survive another day
this is the daily reality of ukrainians
the office of the U.N commissioner for
human rights records over 18
000 civilians deaths and injuries as of
January 23rd
this includes hundreds of innocent
children who's lost the opportunity to
grow up to reach their full potential
the unprovoked and illegal full-scale
invasion of Ukraine by Russia not only
threatens Regional security
impede development and contribute to
widespread human suffering it also
threatens the very fabric of this
intergovernmental organization
the fundamental principles of
international law and entire
International System are as secure
it is time that we all demonstrate our
commitment to uphold the principles of
the UN Charter
in this regard We join cause for the
Russian Federation to immediately and
unconditionally seize hostilities in
Ukraine and allow for a diplomatic
approach to finding comprehensive just
and Lasting peace
excellencies
will live in a world of increasingly in
Connected challenges hence Russia's
aggression against Ukraine also has a
global impact on economic growth and
Global Supply thus aggravating food and
energy crisis for the most vulnerable
States and people
therefore the world cannot and should
not sit back hardly to what is unfolding
in Ukraine
posterity won't judge our actions today
hence the resolution that we will
consider tomorrow since a clear message
that this conflict has to be brought to
an end by restoring respect for the
principles of the U.N Chapel including
the principles of sovereign equality and
territorial Integrity of states
these principles should serve as a basic
for securing a just and Lasting peace in
Ukraine
it is not an approached limited to
Ukraine adherence to the U.N Charter is
a viable and efficient recipe for
addressing issues of Global Peace and
security
I also hessen to remind us that not
speaking out not acting now not doing
the right thing threatens the very
fabric of this intergovernmental body of
which we are all members of
hence Liberia is a proud co-sponsor of
this resolution of further demonstration
of our commitment to the principles of
the U.N Charter maintenance of Global
Peace and security and solidarity with
the people of Ukraine we therefore urge
all member states to vote in favor of
the resolution when it is considered
tomorrow Mr President excellences I
thank you all
I thank the distinguished representative
of Liberia
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Vietnam
Mr President
it has been a year since the outbreak of
the conflict in Ukraine
but Vietnam is saddened to see little
hope in bringing it to a close sooner
than later
despite the passage of time the
situation in Ukraine has regrettably not
shown any sign of de-escalation
the consequences of the conflict are
devastating
with immense loss of life and
destruction of infrastructure and
resources for countries
the impacts of the conflict are felt
globally especially for the most
vulnerable groups
the prospect of negotiations seem Beyond
reach
the conflict has negatively affected the
region and the world and at the same
time hampered efforts aim at promoting
International compression and addressing
Global challenges
if the situation persists chances for
peace are even farther away
it is on the more disheartening at the
time when the world should work
collaboratively for peace and
development
billions of dollars have been spent on
Wars while resources are lacking for
peace development sdgs implementation
and climate change adaptation
Mr President
we reiterate that it is essential to
promote peace security stability and
cooperation through upholding
international law and the United Nations
Charter including fundamental principles
of respect for Independence sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of states and
refrainment from the threat or use of
force
owned disputes should be resolved by
peaceful means through comprehensive and
durable Solutions
we urge party concerned to put an
immediate end to the hostilities and
avoid actions that may lead to further
escalations
we also call upon parties concerned to
urgently resume peaceful dialogue and
negotiations to achieve a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine take
into account the legitimate interests
and needs of the parties in line with
the international law and the U.N
charters
these are the most pressing priorities
at hand
the International Community should
redouble support for these efforts
only by doing so can International and
Regional peace security and stability be
maintained
furthermore Focus must be given to
protecting the Safety and Security of
civilians responding adequately to the
Urgent humanitarian needs of those
impacted by the hostilities and
safeguarding civilian facilities in
particular civilian infrastructure
in this process International assistant
is crucial
we urged the UN member states and
international Partners to continue
joining hands and stepping up
humanitarian assistance to those
impacted by the conflict in Ukraine
Vietnam supports International efforts
and initiatives including those by the
UN and the Secretary General to bring
all parties together
in this film results on of ongoing
initiatives such as the black secret
initiative should serve as the
foundation for finding a comprehensive
solution to the conflict
within our capacity we re-emphasize our
Readiness to make contributions to
diplomatic efforts and to the
Reconstruction recovery and assistance
in Ukraine I thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Vietnam
now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of Peru
foreign
principles
instrumental constitutions obligations
no aggression
Estados
portento the independencia sovereign
presentes
is
percubation
dimensional
El impact Elementary
ostiliates
senior president
is
duradera
independientes
controversies
International
Solutions
International humanitarian porque solo
compas is
Nuevo
Camino casido grave impact
a 16 effects collaterals in consequences
futuro
foreign
[Music]
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Tonga
first degree
Mr President
we gather to Mark already one year past
since the unlawful invasion of Ukraine
by its neighbor the Russian Federation
Tonga again joins others in support
of a peaceful resolution
Aya is a long time
a year full of pain and unnecessary
sufferings
we must remember though
that there always is time to return
to diplomacy
to seek peaceful means
peaceful means as enchant in the United
Nations Charter
Mr President
more than ever we must reaffirm our
commitment to the spirit of togetherness
unity and solidarity
77 years ago having lived
the horrors and destructions of War are
predecessors gathered
to establish
this August body
it was all about hope
the hope for him for Humanity capable of
creating sharing and safeguarding
Lasting peace for all through
International Peace and security
this is why we support the draft
resolution before us entitled uncharter
principles underlying a comprehensive
trust and Lasting peace in Ukraine
we support the purposes and principles
enshrined in the charter of the United
Nations
we support the violations of the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
a U.N member state are inconsistent with
the principles of the uncharter
we support the obligation of all states
under Article 2 of the U.N Charter to
quote refrain in their international
relations
from the threat or use of force against
the territorial Integrity of political
independence of any state
or in any other manner inconsistent with
the Integrity of political independence
of any state or in any
inconsistent
with the
purposes of the United Nations end quote
and we support to settle international
disputes by peaceful means
we call on cessation of the Russian
federation's aggression against Ukraine
and the restoration of lasting peace in
Ukraine
Mr President on that note allow me to
reiterate what had been alluded to by
our delegation in the same session last
year
and in alignment with the Pacific
Islands Forum statement to call upon the
good conscious of all parties to pursue
every possible means available to return
to the path of diplomacy it is never too
late to return to diplomacy
to seek peaceful means
we would all agree with the Secretary
General that the United Nations
is being tested like never before
it was made for moments like this we now
must prove that the purposes and
principles enshrined in the U.N Charter
remain relevant and should therefore be
upheld I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Tonga now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of Sri
Lanka
[Music]
Mr President
distinguished delegates
it is said
that you don't make peace with friends
you make it with unsavory enemies if it
has to be
my dear friends peace talks are always a
complex mix
of strategy calculation and human
emotion
it has been the experience of those
working on peace building programs
and researching peace and conflict
that it is important to pay attention to
both factors to understand why talks may
or may not succeed
between 1946 and 2005
only 39 of 288 conflicts
or 13.5 percent ended in peace
agreements
according to research initiatives
the others ended in Victory for one side
or an end to fighting without a peace
agreement or
a victory straightforward
my dear friends there is also evidence
that even failed
peace agreements
reduce the intensity of future conflict
but even when warring parties
fail to reach a peace agreement
talks reduce civilian casualties through
temporary ceasefires
or the establishment of humanitarian
corridors to deliver supplies or
evacuate civilians
distinguished delegates peace talks can
create a foundation for an eventual
agreement to end conflict
they can also reduce harm to communities
we must therefore strenuously exploit
the crisis
explore the mechanisms of Peace
negotiations to its utmost
with optimism if we are to succeed in
this instance
the easy path of enforcing majoritarian
decisions does not respectfully I say
address their quities in the dispute
resolution mechanism when it comes to
peace talks
Mr President
Sri Lanka therefore remains deeply
concerned about the situation in Ukraine
we call on all parties to exercise
maximum restraint and work towards the
cessation of hostilities in order to
bring about peace security and stability
in the region
Sri Lanka emphasizes the need for
concerted effects to resolve the
situation through diplomacy and dialogue
in the pursuit of peace
as someone said the spiral of death and
Devastation which is growing on a daily
basis does nothing but destroy even the
little trust and hope there is between
the parties to the conflict that peace
was achievable
my dear friends we must appreciate that
globally it has impacted on the recovery
of economies postcovid and on people's
livelihoods
and all countries inclusive of my own
Sri Lanka is affected by increased food
prices Energy prices High inflation and
a debt servicing crisis and increased
levels of migration
Mr President it is important that both
sides must realize that they are being
prejudiced by the status quo but also
know that they cannot have any tangible
military advantage
Mr President the only logical way then
forward is negotiations
and it is in negotiations that we must
place our trust in
we believe that negotiations often
supported by neutral mediators must work
to arrive at some version of a solution
whereby both parties feel that they have
won something
they must Endeavor to craft an agreement
that creates an environment of mutual
gain whether it be political or material
my dear friends we need to be sensitive
to the reality that negotiators must not
only reach an agreement
but also sell that agreement to a
community that is bitter a community
that is traumatized and a community that
is surely grieving
we must always be aware that there are
strong reasons to include also women
Community organizers and different
ethnic leaders in peace talks
the inclusion means that public
acceptance of any peace deal grows as
negotiations proceed
it is known that women and youth and
Community leaders bring up different
dimension
Which is far more conciliatory as they
are more sensitive to the needs of our
future Generations
my dear friends talking with the
generals who are in the battlefield and
the political leaders alone may not
yield the best results
but what we see historically is the
common model of course
and this might well be the case in the
case of Ukraine and Russia
that it would still be up to a few Elite
men to negotiate an agreement and that
might not really work as best as it
ought to Mr President two billion people
live in countries affected by conflict
and humanitarian crises
I do not need to stress the importance
of Peace for without peace no progress
is possible
I am reminded of an observation of the
Holy Father Pope Francis when he said
that there is a global famine for peace
a global famine for peace
that is the pitiful state that we have
successfully brought the world to be in
the prosecution of our Greed for Global
power
what does it I think it was Thomas mus
who said what does it profit a man to
gain the whole world and lose his soul
Mr President we have convened once again
about a year since the conflict in
Ukraine broke out into aggression
creating manifest woeful consequences
both in Ukraine and around the world
during this time this assembly has met
five times before and adopted by what a
number of resolutions
after one year we have not reached a
solution nor do we see one in sight most
respectfully instead the negative
consequences of war and conflict
continue to reverberate around the world
my dear friends if we are to find the
much needed respite for all concerned we
must not give up on diplomacy
and our hope for a future based on peace
and prosperity
we therefore appeal to the principal
parties and the universal Community to
turn to without any further delay
to other mechanisms that include genuine
dialogue and a sincere search for peace
the talks will likely be long and
arduous and require smaller confidence
building steps but it can surely be
brought to an end if we genuinely
address the fundamentals that triggered
the dispute finally my dear friends the
resolution
that we are looking at entitled
principles underlying a comprehensive
just and Lasting piece in Ukraine is
before this assembly for consideration
it is imperative I say that such
initiatives address not just the effects
or the outcome that is evident but the
root causes that led to the conflict
if such root causes are left unaddressed
any peace leave alone a comprehensive
just and Lasting peace in Ukraine would
be elusive
it is Sri Lanka's hope that the decision
we would contribute towards this this
endeavor
and would not be used as another step
towards recriminations and posturing
that would agree with an already
inflamed situation I thank you Mr
President
thank the distinguished representative
of Sri Lanka
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Montenegro
Mr President
uh it has been one year since Russia's
full-scale attack on Ukraine which has
caused death and destruction
on a scale not since since the Second
World War
I hear of indescribable suffering and
bloodshed for the Ukrainian people
tens of thousands of ukrainians have
died including women and children
and millions of civilians are refugees
or are internally displaced
countless war crimes have been committed
by Russian troops as we have heard also
this morning
we once again reiterate our strong
condemnation of the brutal aggression
including deliberate Sheltering of
civilians journalists media actors and
media medical personnel civilian
infrastructure medical facilities
schools educational institutions and
cultural heritage sites in Ukraine
there can be no impunity for war crimes
crimes against humanity and other
atrocity crimes
we welcome and support the ongoing work
to investigate any allegations or
evidence of violation of the
international humanitarian law in terms
of crimes committed in Ukraine
Mr President
the fact that a permanent member of the
security Council and the nuclear State
exercised the brutal force breaching the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
its neighboring country should make
everyone's blood run cold
Russian invasion has put the rules-based
order
that we rely on for peaceful coexistence
under attack
International Peace and security the
ground principles that gathered out
predecessors to build the world Back
From the Ashes and establish the United
Nations our most severely endangered
arguably to the extent never seen in the
post-second world war period the terror
and crimes in Ukraine bring us to the
dark era of brute force in international
relations factoring in solely the hard
power as a way of promoting
self-centered national interests
such aggressive behavior challenges the
international order as we know it today
standing as a pivotal piece of the
Mosaic that guarantees equal rights of
each country with the protection of
Human Rights and fundamental freedoms at
all
the ramifications as many of the
speakers before me said of the Russian
aggression in Ukraine are translated
into growing energy food and financial
crises across the globe which severely
impacts the most vulnerable groups in
least developed countries of the world
therefore we firmly believe that the
multilateralism has to be further
bolstered and a global action to address
these outstanding challenges needs to be
swiftly and carefully crafted and
carried out
Mr President
Montenegro stands with Ukraine and its
people against Russia's aggressive acts
for as long as it takes and it reaffirms
its unwavering support for Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
within its internationally recognized
borders including its territorial Waters
we will not accept Russia's illegal
invasion of a neighboring state
in support of Ukraine and in defense of
the U.N Charter our values democracy and
the rules-based order we must act
decisively
for the reasons outlined Montenegro con
sponsored and we vote in favor of the
resolution as it stands and call others
to do the same thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Montenegro now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of Tunisia
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
foreign
asthma
is
[Music]
the rice
foreign
and now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of the
Syrian Arab Republic
[Music]
shukran said there is
foreign
foreign foreign
say that is
Normandy
Chinese
[Music]
foreign
foreign foreign
[Music]
foreign
Leong
is Hammond
Isiah
rusi
foreign
Theo Krang
until
[Music]
that is
foreign
[Music]
shukran say the rice
is
[Music]
and now I give the floor to the
distinguished representative of
Argentina
of humans
particularly
foreign
which puts an end to the conflict thank
you I think the distinguish
representative of Argentina now I give
the flow to the distinguished
representative of Palau
Mr President Secretary General
excellencies colleagues we align
ourselves with the statement made by
Fiji as chair of the Pacific island
forum and we make the following
statement in our national capacity
a year is a milestone we often associate
with celebrations a baby's first
birthday a complete cycle of Seasons the
Earth's full rotation around the Sun
it's unfortunate that today we are
commemorating the year anniversary of
Russia's illegal unprovoked invasion of
Ukraine
a year in which hundreds of thousands
have died
whole cities have been raised civilian
homes and infrastructure turn to Rubble
six million people in Ukraine have been
internally displaced and eight million
people have fled into other parts of
Europe that's nearly the population of
this very dense city of New York
many of these are women and children
it's also a war that's inflamed an
energy inflation and food security
crisis in every corner of our world
on this day we commend The Bravery
strength and Valor of ukrainians who
have stood their ground and defended
their independence and Homeland
Russia may have projected a quick
Victory given its size and power but
instead in the pulverized Runes of
dambas and in bomb shelters across
Ukraine ukrainians have forged
themselves Anew into a unified more
resilient democracy it's a demonstration
that there are few forces more powerful
than one spirit in defense of home
we also mourn the sons and daughters and
mothers and fathers from Russia who've
been sent to fight in this senseless war
men and women with potential who've been
sent to die in defense of a false
ideology
sanctions in an exodus of its best
educated citizens and private
multinational corporations and
institutions have soft Russia's
long-term economic prospects yet our
colleague from Russia stood here earlier
and recycled false statements that have
been refuted by independent institutions
with an aim to deflect and Gaslight us
but to Palau there's simply no
justification to an unprovoked invasion
on Sovereign territory when we became a
UN member State and promised to uphold
the U.N Charter it was not in vain we
reiterate our solidarity to Ukraine and
call on Russia to end their aggression
in Ukraine's territorial borders
colleagues many of us are fatigued by
this war in the midst of the triple
planetary crisis in our work on reaching
the sdgs we've had to dedicate many
hours of scarce diplomatic resources to
this issue
but we must not falter in our defense of
the U.N Charter so when you're tired
think of Andre a fighter pilot who
finally took a break after almost 19
hours of Defense measures too exhausted
to fly anymore his commanding officer
spooning stew into his mouth to revive
him think of Vitale who ignored warnings
that his name was on a list of people
whom Russia's forces had been instructed
to kill and set about turning his
anti-corruption organization into a
network to support the Armed Forces
think of the Ukrainian children who live
in Terror of being shot or shelled or
abducted into Russia
think of 64 year old Natalya who Shivers
without heat in the bone-chilling
Ukrainian winter
think of them but also be reminded that
the war the way this war plays out will
set a precedent for our world order
going forward
might it be on your own home countries
where a larger aggressor takes his
chances buoyed by the inaction of the
world to defend internationally
recognized territorial borders
as Russia's offensive campaign and
illegitimate claim to sovereignty over
several areas of Ukraine show no signs
of abating it's critical that we U.N
member states sustain these
institutional measures and deepen our
commitment not only to securing a just
resolution of the conflict in which
Ukraine's territory Integrity is
maintained but also one in which victims
of the many grave violations that have
been committed are able to abstain
Justice and redress
if you came Ukraine thrives so does a
rules-based international order and the
lesson will reverberate around the world
it will be the prologue to a more stable
piece Palau will be voting in favor of
the draft resolution as it stands we
call on all member states to join us
thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
of Palau now I give the flow to the
distinguished representative of
Azerbaijan
Mr President after one year of eruption
of armed hostilities
the situation in and around Ukraine
remains to be a matter of profound
profound concern
as it continues to pose a serious threat
to peace and security at the regional
and Global levels
a particular concern is the other
increased humanitarian impact
as civilians
mainly women children and elderly
continue to Bear the major burden of
prolonged armed hostilities
in this connection Azerbaijan takes
consistent steps in its National
capacity
to help the people of Ukraine alleviate
the dire humanitarian consequences
and continuously provides humanitarian
assistance to Ukraine
Azerbaijan stands for the earliest
settlement
exclusively through peaceful diplomatic
means in full compliance with the norms
and principles of international law
guiding Interstate relations including
the respect for the sovereignty to
Eternal integrity and invalability of
borders
and encourages
the dialogue between the parties to that
end
I thank you
I thank the distinguished representative
Azerbaijan
now I give the flow to the distinguished
representative of Greece
[Music]
Mr President distinguished delegates
it is truly inconceivable that you are
here today in this Hall to discuss an
amprovoked unjustified war that started
a year ago
a war launched by Russia against Ukraine
is stuck violation of the U.N Charter
international law and all the principles
and values that unite us a word that
shook to the core of the foundation of
this very Organization for Greece there
are no gray areas of this war the
situation is as simple as black and
white
there is a side that attacks and inside
the defense
Greece has stood on the right side of
this war since the first day of the
Russian invasion in full solidarity
support of the one who was called to
fight for the sovereignty Independence
and freedom of the country
in the face of such aggression we
command the character determination of
the Ukrainian people a people who is
fighting against a threat that must be
confronted by the national Community as
a whole
from the very beginning there was an
assumption that the European Union would
fail to remain United in the face of
this crisis but the exact opposite
happened they Union its member states
represent a region where human rights
and respect of international law are
invited to thrive
these core principles Center The Heart
of Greece foreign policy if we fail to
defend them we will be shooting
ourselves in the foot in this period
along with our ego partners and NATO
allies we fully support the territorial
Integrity of Ukraine within its
International recognized borders as such
we condemn and do not recognize the
illegal annexation of the autonomous
Republic of Crimea and the City of
Sebastopol by the Russian Federation nor
do we recognize the self-proclaimed
Donetsk and luhan's People's Republic
immediately following Russia's Invasion
my country was among the first to
respond to Crane's requests for military
assistance Greece also fully implements
extensive Equity selective measures
against Russia regardless of the serious
repercussion for its economy
Greece continues to provide humanitarian
assistance medicine and other supplies
both in Ukraine as well as Ukrainian
refugees hosted in neighboring countries
my country is committed to being present
in reconstruction efforts and assists to
Crane on this European path
the war took a heavy toll also the Greek
populations that have been present in
the Black Sea region for millennials and
one striving Greek Community lived
mostly in areas now on the Russian
occupation particularly in the city of
mariopol which the Greek Minister of
Foreign Affairs Mrs dendias visited only
a month before the logic of the Russian
invasion
to our knowledge this vibrant city which
is busy commercial port to days a ghost
town an important Greek Community still
living in Ukraine today and it's greatly
suffering the recurrent Russian attacks
against Ukraine's critical
infrastructure energy Heating and water
supply system houses and medical
facilities are unacceptable and no
circumstances can civilians be the
legitimate targets the violations of
international humanitarian law and war
crimes must be investigated and the
perpetrators must be held accountable
if not stopped Russian military's
aggression against Ukraine may find
imitators willing to pursue
anachronistic revisionist agendas
allow me to repeat we stand in full
solidarity with a partner Ukraine and we
will continue to support Ukraine for as
long as it takes thank you so much
I thank the distinguished representative
of Greece
now I give the flow to the distinguished
Observer of the Observer state of the
Holy See
Mr President
as these emergency special sessions
observes the one-year anniversary of the
escalation of the war in Ukraine
let us never forget that peace is
possible
in this regard all parties must remain
open to dialogue lest there is closing
off the only reasonable door to peace
subscribing to the illusion that this
war as a military solution through
attrition will lead to no peace other
than the Dreadful peace of death
with this in mind Pope Francis has made
the following heartfelt appeal
May weapons be silenced and make
conditions be sought for the start of
negotiations that will lead to solutions
that are not imposed by force but
consensual just and stable
the humanity of Modern Warfare is on
display in Ukraine for all to see
as each life lost lives behind a
grieving family with parents forced to
bury their sons and daughters
and children left orphaned a status that
has no nationality
particularly reprehensible is the
Reliance on tactics that treat soldiers
as expandable objects rather than in
human beings with invaluable dignity
throughout the war Pope Francis
closeness to the innocent in Ukraine who
suffered the martyrdom of aggression
in this regard the Holy See Julia caused
the obligation of all states according
to International humanitarian law
to refrain from evacuating children to
foreign territory without a compelling
medical reason and the written consent
of those responsible for their care or
from changing their personal status
in addition the Holy See insists on the
importance of family reunification
including of children with their
extended family
and cause on all states to ensure the
best interest of the child at all times
children must never become the Pawns of
war or used for political propaganda
in light of attacks against critical
infrastructure
they only see rhetories that any Act of
War aim indiscriminately at the
destruction of entire cities of
extensive areas along with their
population is a crime against God and
Men himself
it marries an equivocal and unhesitating
condemnation
in the face of Civilian suffering my
delegation renews its gratitude to those
governments organizations and
individuals that have embodied the ethic
or solidarity in providing shelter food
and medical care to those displays
within Ukraine and in neighboring
countries
for its part the Holy See has provided
Aid to those in need in Ukraine through
the Deacon study for the service of
Charity while The Wider Catholic Church
through religious orders lay communities
and faith-based organizations on the
ground
has delivered assistance to millions of
those in need including refugees of War
Mr President
the repercussion of the present War
extends far beyond Ukraine having
spurred energy food and financial crisis
that particularly affect those in the
poorest countries
in this regard the Holy See welcomes the
implementation of the Black Sea grain
initiative and commence the continued
work of the Secretary General and turkey
in ensuring the success and full
implementation of the Accord which
demonstrates the viability of dialogue
to lessen the suffering caused by War
absurdly the present world portends the
risk of nuclear disasters either through
deliberate escalation or accident caused
by inadvertent damage to nuclear
facilities
with regard to the former the only sea
cannot help but condemn any rhetoric
threatening the use of nuclear weapons
as morally repugnant given that their
indiscriminate effects violate the laws
of war and would have devastating
consequences for all Humanity
in this regard the olesis supports the
efforts of the international atomic
energy agency to create a protection
zone for the evaporation Nuclear Power
Plant
Mr President
the present conflict makes playing the
significant dysfunction present in these
organization's security architecture and
that of the entire multilateral system
addressing such a dysfunction demands
comprehensive reform that opposed the
principle of sovereign equality of all
states
institutional reforms alone however
cannot save us from the scourge of War
which originates from within the human
heart corrupted by sin
it's time to refrain from any rhetoric
or action seeking to escalate this
conflict and engage in concrete dialogue
and diplomacy in a sincere attempt to
put an end to this anus War
no effort must be spared to end the
suffering of the Ukrainian people and
all those somehow affected by these
atrocious conflict
I thank you Mr President
I thank the distinguished Observer of
the Holy See and now I give the flow to
the distinguished Observer of The
Sovereign Order of Malta
Mr President Excellence is
distinguished colleagues
War undoubtedly has the effect
of breaking down the structures of
society
the very structures that are there to
protect us
and in so doing
War imposes on human beings in the words
of philosopher Thomas Hobbes a human
condition which is solitary
cruel nasty
brutish and short
conditions that are equally shared
by both the victim and the aggressor
over the past 12 months the escalation
of hostilities in Ukraine
the internal and external displacement
of over 8 million people with Millions
more living in Daily fear through their
lives
the humanitarian and National and
international Aid Community has been a
key lifeline and a link
between a deteriorating Human Condition
and the possibility of Hope
and that hope
is enshrined in the words of Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez
when he said we want a world
to be defined by the values enshrined in
the United Nations Charter
peace
Justice
respect human rights tolerance and
solidarity
and this remains our strongest tool in
achieving Harmony
not only between human beings
between ukrainians and Russians
but also between us and our planet
extending here I'd like to quote Pope
John the 23rd in his seminal encyclical
parchment Terrace
when he says this since we are social by
Nature
we must live together and consult each
other's interests
we should recognize and perform our
respective rights and duties
which are imperative to a well-ordered
society
the past 12 months have seen
almost a total breakdown in this social
contract in a part of the world formally
marked by promise and Industry
the Bread Basket of the world
not only have we witnessed the
devastating destruction of Ukraine but
we have seen also a breakdown in The
Wider context of international civil
discourse
crucial question is can we put it right
well we all have a role to play in
contributing to a better world
tomorrow
it's a challenge for each of us right
now
sadly it seems this war
has no sign of slowing down therefore we
must all maintain our humanitarian
support for the people of Ukraine
is it not time for more of us to turn
our swords into plowshares
like many armies of Aid agencies The
Sovereign Order of Malta and
representatives of other religious
Catholic and faith-based organizations
maintain a presence at the Ukrainian
border as does our work within the
country providing 24-hour assistance to
refugees families displaced persons
individuals trapped by conflict through
medical social projects psychological
support the provision of Health hygiene
products food housing and we've recently
announced an increase in psychosocial
support and Aid programs across our
teams
this year of conflict has led to social
financial and political environmental
effects that have reverberated across
the planet
back in 2015 when the sustainable
development goals were introduced it was
a moment in time representing a more
conscious attitude towards Global
development and diplomacy one that
encouraged transparency and
accountability not only how we work for
our future but more importantly why it
is essential to work for our future
and with continuing crises requiring
attention of the International Community
the devastating effects of this war
sadly represent
a marginal level of problems we continue
to face as a collective Humanity
the recent tragedies in Pakistan in
Turkey in Syria remind us that natural
disasters and their consequences remain
out of our immediate control
while inhibiting our success in
achieving the 2030 agenda
and whilst Russia's aggression in
Ukraine has created the world's largest
displacement crisis countries in the
Horn of Africa continue to fast to face
droughts that have led to a catastrophic
rise in hunger moreover we have
witnessed entire Generations across the
world being pushed into extreme poverty
as well as horrifically high death tolls
from the 26 other conflicts that are
being perpetuated on our landscape
climate change continues to wound
countries that are without the
infrastructure to deal with it
sufficiently
and the sustainable development goals
continue to extend further Out Of Reach
to those who most need them
next month sees the U.N Water conference
here in New York and while access to
clean water is an issue faced more often
than not by developing countries
due to the war in Ukraine more than 6
million ukrainians have either limited
or no access to clean water
we must all recognize that the setbacks
that nature continues to throw in our
path are already enough
to keep us from reaching the targets of
the sdgs
simply put we cannot afford any type of
War if we want to meet the climate
battle for ourselves
and make it for our future Generations
distinguished colleagues
if we fail to find a workable solution
to the war in Ukraine and if our
plowshares of Aid and humanitarian
assistance
continue to run out or be compromised
then a hobbesian image
will become ever more real
and peace and Security will give way to
something that is cruel brutish and
short
I thank the distinguished Observer of
the sovereign
ladies and Gentlemen We Have Heard the
Last speaker in the debate and this item
for this evening
we shall hear the remaining speakers
tomorrow
23rd of February starting at 10 o'clock
sharp in this hole
this meeting is adjourned